Do you know what?
I'll see you later,
man.
Five oh three two
[inaudible] and we're live.
Yes,
dude.
Fucking crazy weekend.
Huh?
What the hell?
Watch those three title fights.
That was like,
he was really funny because we were talking about this and you were like,
this is probably one of the best cards ever,
but we have a high likelihood of all decisions.
Yeah,
yeah.
Boy was I wrong.
Goddamn was I wrong?
I make some good pics but every now and then I just,
I looked at the matchup.
I'm like,
everyone's so close in competition and skill wise.
I was like,
we're going to get a lot of decisions,
which I don't mind and then as we're watching,
I'm glad I was wrong.
As you're watching like coal Lee Shit,
best UFC card ever.
I don't know what was the most surprising outcome too.
It's like did you just crack yourself and just hit the antlers?
Jamie,
a CTA.
Just rent.
I told you there was a bad idea to put that thing there.
All right,
we're going to put it out like a red light.
We've got an elk antler right over near with Jamie has to want it.
It's the,
it's the hat with a brim,
like the brim flock been there forever and I'm not stare right.
Racial awareness and getting used to the space.
Fuck man.
Um,
so I think maybe one of the most impressive things or confusing or unexpected
was how fucking good GSP looked.
That dude's gone for four years,
comes back and immediately I see them moving around and popping a jab and I'm
like,
Jesus Christ,
he looks like GSP.
He now hold.
Yeah.
I see.
I wasn't,
I wasn't that.
And everyone's like,
oh,
here's Schild the hate or no,
I wasn't that in love with GSPS performance.
I thought he looked good.
I thought he looked heavy.
I didn't think he looked as,
you know,
obviously he put on some pounds thick.
He was thick,
thick,
like three musketeer thick.
I thought he put,
he put on some pounds in his cardio,
wasn't that great.
And yet could go for days before.
Yeah,
he definitely was suffering a little bit because of that.
And also it has to be a big factor for years off just the nerves and all the
huge factor and a struggle to hold Bisbing down.
This makes fucking heart and you know,
honestly taking him down was one of the worst things that could have happened.
He got cut the fuck up.
It's been top work down there and when I was worried if it went to decision,
I thought Bisping's actually winning even though just he got him down for that
portion.
If the,
if the,
hopefully the judges see that Bisping's doing the damage done that should count
in their eyes.
I agree.
I agree 100% the only time that's ever really counted though in a,
in a fight is Kevin Randleman versus boss Rutan.
Remember Kevin Random?
I took boss written down,
but bas Rutten was beating the shit out of him from the bottom and random and
dude and do anything in bed.
A lot of people who are super outraged after that decision.
Yeah,
that was a weird one because most of the fight was spent with boss on the bottom
and random and on top.
That's old school.
I think,
I think just be obviously looked great.
Pass the test.
I didn't see,
I always look what's next.
I didn't think,
I thought Bisping was super hesitant because for this reason they trained
earlier.
Right.
They train in 2008 and I guess I guess 2006 so a while ago I guess GSB just kind
of mopped the floor with them,
like kind of do whatever we want.
So then I think GSPs camp and their,
their thinking was all right,
middle middleweights really not where we should be at,
but business is kind of easy picking for us.
We might as well go get the belt from here if we're going to do this big
comeback.
So I,
so I think he thought it was a good match up and I think because they trained
prior that wasn't normal busy being busy and pushes the pace.
I think he was so worried about the takedown.
Rightfully so.
I don't,
I don't think that business Dan looked great to me either.
No,
he looked very super hesitant and staff and he looked like father time was like,
Yo man,
tonight,
I don't think it was a father time thing.
I think it was in the back of his mind and he was very openly admitting that GSP
dominated those training sessions that they had in 2006 and he was saying,
look,
I'm much better than I was back then,
which I'm sure he is,
but you can only get so much better.
It's also a mental thing like,
like Dan when he did that and he's impossible to get off.
So yeah,
I think he was very reserved,
but I just,
I thought again,
I thought after four years,
hell yeah George,
like good.
Did George looked good enough to beat like a Whitaker or Yoel Romero?
Probably not.
Not to hate on his,
not to hate on what's going on right now.
Cause the epic night,
I just look at the real middle weights gaining Whitaker,
UL,
Luke,
Rockhold.
It went with those cardio problems.
I was like,
this was a fun one and you're crazy if you think he's gonna fight again.
85 they didn't happen?
I don't think so either.
I can promise you that's not happening.
I think he drops right back down and wants to fight and Woodley neck.
Yeah.
When I was thinking about him fighting and Woodley's no fucking picnic.
That's not a cakewalk.
Matchup wise,
it's very tough for GSP.
We know Woodley's been dealing with a shoulder injury.
He hurt his shoulder pretty bad in that fight early in the Thompson fight.
And so what he does about that is what?
That,
that that's what,
that's what's up in the air.
If he chooses to have surgery,
I believe he has.
I don't know if he's talked about it,
but I think he has a labor.
I'm tear.
So it was the question is what he decides to do about that.
I heard him say about Colby Covington and we should talk about him.
He's killing me.
Right.
Leave it.
Yeah,
but a good way.
But he was saying,
he goes,
yeah,
my shoulder's messed up,
but it's good enough where I could whip Colbys ass.
That was a good enough to whip GSP.
Probably not,
but Whitaker's out to.
Yeah.
If you,
if it occurs almost back,
if they do another intern belt had welterweight,
I'm going to bus,
I'm going to freak out if there's more intern belt on.
Where the fuck out?
If they do,
who would do,
what would they do?
Well,
if Woodley has to do surgery and then GSPs one Covington.
Oh my God.
Or GSP versus someone down there.
GSP versus somewhere.
We get a lot of press.
Yep.
They think they got over a million paper view by Saturday night.
I hope so.
Yeah.
I thought I thought it was going to do around seven hundreds they might've got a
million just from Canada.
They said Canada was tracking higher than the paper.
The paper view for Mayweather versus Macgregor.
Yeah.
Canada.
Come on.
Canada's crazy for GSP Robinson,
GSP.
I mean he won the athlete of the year back in the UFC was like not nearly as
popular.
It's true.
He's gray.
Rhonda and pre Connor.
He won athlete of the year till now.
I'll see.
There's the Conor McGregor effect,
but there's no one that you'll see.
You can go to Canada and sell out the bell center.
Do you know giant Trump?
Now you can do that.
His next fight,
you can go up there and do that.
Oh my God,
his next fight.
Now he's the middle weight champion of the world.
Holy Shit.
Jesus Christ known as contract.
And Dana said this,
but contracts are like pinky swears in the UFC there kind of like,
all right,
whatever.
You know what I'm saying?
I think you know in his contract he has east end,
he said this and it's in his contract.
He has to defend the middle for the middleweight title.
But again,
I don't think it's gonna happen cause you hear if Freddie Roach talked about how
85 is not where he wants to be at when they asked him what's next.
And then also remember all this adds up.
It's easy to figure out enough to be fucking Sherlock Holmes.
Whitaker was cage side.
If that fight was next,
the way you rip your promos,
bring Whitaker into the cage.
They're like,
Nah son,
you're good.
You sit there,
you ain't coming in here.
We don't need that right now.
Sober.
October's over.
It's definitely over.
Yeah.
I don't know man Whittaker a I'm sure would want that fight,
but hell yeah.
You want that fight.
I don't think GSP was ever really considering it.
No,
I don't.
It's just not a possibility.
I think Julie's next,
but yeah,
with Woodley injured,
here's the real queasy question.
Um,
if Connor defends against Tony,
and that's a big fight,
which I heard is a march.
That's the rumors.
What do you think about GSP versus God?
I know,
right?
I'm whispering because it's crazy.
A lot of things have to happen in order for that to line up.
So condoms,
Tony Little weight,
which I think he's down to do.
He was a gorilla when I interviewed him at the weigh ins and I put my arm on it.
I was like,
fuck dude,
he's giant.
It's too much.
It was just too much.
It was like,
Ooh.
Yeah,
it's just,
he's way bigger.
Like he looked like 200 plus pounds when he got into his frames.
So much bigger than Conor.
But just the magnitude of that fight,
they do that.
A catch weight,
that's a super fight when we're talking about super fights now that's a mother
fucking super five would have to be at one 70 but if they did do it at one 70
Connor would have to get through.
Tony GSPs going to have to beat Woodley.
Then you get to end of next year.
There's a lot that's the lineup because Connor Beaton,
if Tony's a giant him,
even if he doesn't,
it's still super flight.
Right?
If he loses by devastating knockout,
it's not a super fun.
And you know,
probably to see,
not going to see GSP and yet,
you know,
the thing about Woodley is if Woodley wins,
you're probably going to the hospital unless your name's Wonderboy.
And then we'll probably go into sleep on the couch as a fan.
Well one,
but Wonderboy fight at least went to decision.
But there was moments in that fight where it looked like wonder boy was going
out.
Hell yeah.
I mean,
Woodley puts people,
excuse me,
Woodley puts people to sleep mean he hits fucking heart.
But here's the question.
Like what,
how much damage has been done to shoulder and what needs to be,
I mean,
it's a labor him tear,
whatever sort of a tear it is.
Can it be fixed with stem cells?
Can it be fixed with rehab or is it damaged to the point where he's going to
need surgery?
Because if he does,
he's likely out a year.
That's what Cain had.
Cain had labor.
Surgery comes out for a year.
That's a rough one to,
to to reform.
Yeah.
It's not,
it's not an easy road back and especially [inaudible] excuse me.
For someone who has that,
um,
wild po punching style like Woodley,
think about how much fucking torque that guy puts in his punches and he might be
the heaviest hitter in the history of the 170 pound division.
You watch that fight with Josh Koscheck a watch that fight with Jay hair on
dude.
He had at the Johnson was cutting the 70.
That's begs to differ.
That's different.
He had no business being done.
Yeah,
but I hear you,
especially right now.
He know he's talking about coming back as a heavyweight.
I know.
And which is good cause that division needs it.
Does need them.
But why is he?
I don't get it.
Yeah,
I don't get it either.
He said he didn't want to fight anymore,
but he's like,
he's done well.
He thought he was done.
He thought that's the life he wants.
Then when you're there you're like,
oh this sucks.
Oh wait,
I feel actually pretty good.
I can go to heavyweight.
Not Cut all that way.
I wonder in the division slim,
but how much weight is it really cutting at two oh five probably 30 pounds.
You think you've walked around up at two 35 so he's a freak man.
It's so much weight.
So,
so much weight.
He's absolute freak.
So I made a good point.
Use either you or DC who,
by the way,
my MVP,
everyone tore it up.
Ms Square Garden,
DC.
DC is stealing my heart man,
as a commentator.
That mother is good.
He's bringing some personality to it.
He's himself.
Yes,
he sees himself like in Brasilia a little too excited in the cage,
but he's great man til the shock killer shot thriller show.
He's great when he's like,
ah,
I can't talk right now.
So No,
I love that.
When when rose one and he starts yelling out,
fuck round.
Yes,
I want that.
I want that too.
That's what I want.
Yes.
Everyone doing it.
Take notes.
Be Yourself.
DC's not being fake.
Yeah,
but he's living in the moment.
DC is fucking hilarious.
Yeah.
DC has one of the best personalities ever when you're hanging around him,
like outside of commentary,
outside of the fire.
People don't know him and it's,
it's a,
it's a goddamn shame that people boo him love that they should love him.
His personality is amazing.
So when he's himself,
that himself is great.
Like me and him are always,
excuse me,
God damn weed.
Me and him are always laughing and slapping each other on these.
Awesome.
Brian laughing.
He's the best.
He grew up in locker rooms so he's going to know that Chit Chat.
You know what I'm saying?
He knows the vice.
I'll funny,
smart and he knows a shit load about wrestling to what a,
what an asset he is.
Whenever there's some sort of a take down attempt or someone doing something
wrong and he can explain it.
That's the,
that's the future man and he's good at it and wants to do it.
Yeah,
he's great man.
He's great,
but the thug rose home was my favorite.
He's hilarious.
He's just being himself.
But it was either him or you that made the point of,
you know,
you really got to give it up to Woodley for what he did to wonder,
boy,
when you see what wonderful,
we did a 100% with Wonderboy.
Does everybody,
well,
everybody,
this is the reason why I felt it was unfair to criticize Woodley because if I
was in Woodley's corner,
I would have told him to fight the exact same fight.
Like people have said to me after the comedy,
like,
why didn't you say that that fight was boring?
I go,
go was,
it wasn't boring.
It wasn't boring to me while I was happening.
It might be boring if you knew what happened and you had to watch the four
rounds before.
If you're not like really into tactics and try to figure out what's happening.
But to me there's just dire consequences to any mistake you make against
Woodley.
And there's dire consequences against wonderful,
really wonderful.
I think w with woodland,
the Wonderboy battle,
I think they're just bad dance partners,
but I also think you make one mistake,
and against Wonderboy especially,
you know,
Woodley be in shorter,
you're in a lot of fucking trouble.
And he knew that.
Now to me,
the fight wasn't great.
There weren't great.
That last one was in great,
but there were times when it was good,
but I think the way Woodley dealt with it and kind of figured it out,
you said this on the,
on the commentary on the broadcast where that might be the only way to beat
Wonderboy.
Yep.
That's it.
It's gonna.
It's not gonna be exciting fights and I can be great.
And Woodley figured that out.
Now when you go to the Maya fights,
like God dammit,
you know,
when he'd go over there and then it's another thing.
But again,
the Maya fight though,
if he did hurt his shoulder early in the fight,
think about dealing with a guy who was one of the best fucking nightmares ever.
Nightmare ever.
Being in a position where you can't use one of your arms,
right.
Nightmare.
You almost have to fight the way he fought against Maya.
You don't want to go to the ground and people like kill you,
fucking Tyron Woodley,
apologist,
your timing Woodley lever.
No,
it is what it is.
I,
I think it just lined up for him where it's like this was this,
this is the much you're dealing with.
Then you get the shoulder,
he needs a guy like Colby.
Yes.
Cory comes in and I sent you a screenshot of his,
I will up to this Twitter where Colby and his twist Jon Jones.
I told Coby,
this was saying on my show.
I was saying,
you know,
people say,
hey man,
let's not cross the line and with Colby,
you listen to me right now.
You find that line,
you fucking run through it.
Whatever you're doing is working,
man,
don't get racist but run through that fucking line and he's from Brazil on his,
his fucking social media presence has gone through the roof.
Like when people,
when people think of him has gone through the roof,
most more people were talking about him now than ever before was ranked number
three.
Number three in the world.
They're talking about a title shot.
Well,
he did beat the shit out of Damien Maia.
He beat the off in Brazil,
wore his ass out and it was only a three round fight.
I mean,
who knows?
It was a five round fight.
He might've got to stop.
It will stop them.
Yeah.
Very mom might've beating the shit out of him.
And Colby is,
he's young,
he's brash.
He's fucking tough as shit.
Look at this.
John Jones says the George Saint Pierre.
Hey George Saint Pierre.
You've always been one of my biggest inspirations.
Show the world how great you can be tonight praying for you.
Toby coming to says,
shut up.
Loser,
exclamation point.
You're the biggest fuck up in the history of sports.
Hashtag UFC seven to 17 two places.
Why is he going so hard in the paint at Jon Jones?
He doesn't care man,
but it's working because I like what row says in the rose.
I thought was the biggest MVP of the night,
but I liked what rose says.
She's like,
man,
I'm sick of this fight culture.
Rammer guys are just going super hard in the paint talking shit and not being
themselves like I'm a good person.
Let's be nice to each other.
I'm like,
Kelly,
I love that shit rose.
And then I opened up my Twitter but he told me,
I'm like,
but then that also made sense like you have this angel,
you know what I'm saying?
A demon on my shoulder like Gat Colby.
No rose,
this is nice.
You know,
it all makes sense.
Look,
it's exciting.
The shit talking is exciting.
Yeah.
I like when they make up afterwards.
That's what I'm happy.
Yeah,
I'll talk plenty.
Shit.
They fight and then they make up TJ and Cody really didn't,
I really don't like I respect you.
And then Cody Cody's like,
yeah,
I respect them,
but I,
everything I said was true.
Fuck that guy.
Well,
when,
when Tj got in his face right after the stoppage and was like touching his
facts,
when she gets out screaming out,
when you're dealing with a fight of that magnitude and there's that much high
emotion and passion,
there's going to be a little bit of that.
But I never send anybody to do that before.
I never saw anybody wind by stoppage.
And then when the guy gets up just fucking out of it,
t J's in his face at the top of his lungs with his mouth touching his face.
Like he was kissing him like he was a baby bird and he was like on his tippy
toes,
like [inaudible] stature,
just shredded too.
Amazing picture.
But that,
but again,
you know,
with Cody had all that ammunition just the week of like,
oh,
I didn't knock you out,
drops the video.
And I was like,
Oh fuck.
I think one of the worst things that happen,
uh,
for Cody is that he got that knockdown cause we'd like to do it again.
What you're saying in practice or in the first fight in the first round.
Look at that.
That is insane.
I mean,
are coaches,
yeah,
lip to lip.
Currently they're kissing essentially kissing Cody is completely out of it.
Right?
It just got knocked out cold.
I wasn't sure if he was out cold,
but if you watch the stop it,
she stops moving.
He got hit a buzzer stoppage.
He came right back.
God,
I should stop coughing.
Right.
All let both those guys,
he came right back.
He got back up like pretty quickly,
but I think that's conditioning and just realizing that he,
you know,
he came to,
but he's a monster Co.
Look at the Tj shredding shred here.
How the fuck is he going to cut 10 more pounds to go down and fight mighty
mouse.
Mm.
Do they do a catch weight to the belts?
Really fucking matter.
They're going to do it at one 25 John One toy.
Tj Sweat.
When I talked to Tj,
he swears he didn't make,
he goes all day easily.
You might be able to hit it too.
Hey,
mighty mouse.
Who else do you get in a fight,
but if he gets a Mike Dolce behind him or George Lockhart or one of those weight
cut teachers to list.
Yeah,
he has someone.
He does.
He has some guy.
He's a monster.
That's why it looks like that right now.
Here's some new guy that he moved to California four.
If you get a guy who's awake,
cutting expert,
I bet he could probably do it.
Oh,
he'll do it for sure.
He wanted to do it.
Originally he was already making the cut when he thought it was going to happen.
It was like it.
He goes,
it's no problem.
Was very disappointed in that fight and I see his point,
but I also see my knee mouses point.
Mighty mouse is pointing as liquid.
If TJ doesn't make the cut and then I lose the fight.
Like what if he doesn't make the weight and then I lose the fight to him.
He's like,
that's a big deal and I don't.
Yeah,
and I don't set the record.
Yeah.
He wanted to set the record.
The record was giant him.
He wanted to set the record in his weight class.
So he said,
look,
I have one requirement,
let Tj when a fight at one 25 then fight at one 25 let him win and then I'll
have them come over or get them jacked as after you one.
That's real too man.
I mean that's some raw shit.
That's some raw emotion.
Where there,
how much?
There was so much during an fight.
Three more times.
There's so much shit talking going on.
A new,
so personal for these two.
Yeah.
Boy He look bad.
When he got clipped you got clipped at the end of the first round and it looks
like wow,
really bad.
We'll be has a piston for a right hand.
Unbelievable speed.
But then he came back real quick like at the beginning of the second round,
he looked fine.
He looked amazing.
He looked fine,
like didn't look at anything's wrong with them.
They start throwing a lot more kicks.
And did you see what a Tj said?
Cause they're like,
oh,
you're going to give uh,
Cody immediate rematch.
He goes,
hell no.
Look at the fire out to walk through to get back here.
He goes,
it doesn't work like that.
True.
He was,
does not work like that to fight what three guy?
I have to wait over a year.
Fight three monsters.
You got to find out Linacre.
Yeah.
By the way,
he fucking neutralized Linacre too.
That was one of the more,
in my opinion,
one of the more fascinating fights because I don't think there's another guy in
the division that would have neutralized Linacre in that way and not getting hit
agree.
You didn't mean maybe Dominic Dominic.
But the thing about t j versus Dominic is Tj is more kick oriented.
T TJ can,
he's not the,
Dominic doesn't have kicks,
but I think Tj has more flexibility is more loose in the outside key.
Tj Wins by head kick.
Right.
He head kicks guys.
He will,
he will do all of the above.
You know,
he's,
he doesn't have a in any way eliminated arsenal and I don't know what they're
going to do next.
But you know,
Dominic was,
Jimmy Rivera is a tough,
tough,
tough to me.
I don't know what Jimmy Rivera as a Fox like Tang nightmare people,
people,
he's undefeated.
He kind of mopped the floor with your I favor like he's no joke man flying under
the radar.
But yeah,
he is.
And his head is twice as big as either one of us.
The tank at that weight class and his,
his low kick,
that low kicked that everyone's doing that below the calf kick or that calf
kick.
God Damn,
that is a debilitating kick dudes.
My dark horse,
no one's really talking about,
I'm like God,
he's a showman guy.
You know,
when I was,
uh,
in the martial arts in New York in like that area,
tigers showmen had like a whole chain of karate schools and I'm,
I'm sure they did competitions and stuff.
I'm pretty sure,
but no one ever would have thought they would become like a powerhouse for MMA.
But they've had quite a few like really talented fighters last there.
Well,
they had that kid with the green hair.
The fuck's his name.
Bantamweight Gentlemen.
Oh.
Uh,
I didn't even fucking talking about God.
My campus members,
I do.
Dan Stop.
He stopped fighting.
I did.
It kind of just dipped out.
Right.
He's like,
I'm out.
They have that kid,
so this is going to be a lot of,
they have that kid,
I can't remember this either.
Sorry to put you on the spot.
Oh yeah.
Where at one of his other guys had this crazy choke that uh,
we had to like go over in the gym and try to figure out yes.
Yeah.
Those garden.
No.
Yep.
Sorry.
Louis Louis goes,
no,
he was one of my faves though.
Tough dude.
He's a,
he's a believe he's a tiger Schulman guy.
I'm pretty sure.
Um,
and then,
uh,
there's been a few other guys too.
The only one who's going to get a rematch on the card is Yolana.
She deserves it after,
after defendant tile that many times he hit murked in that first round.
I think she's that,
that qualifies for immediate rematch.
Well,
I think that's where the big money is for sure.
I mean,
people are gonna want to see that.
That's a big fight because when,
when you wanna um,
walked out to the pop from the audience was immense.
She's finally become like this star that they've been putting all this promotion
into her.
She's winning fights.
Yeah.
She was kind of thriving in it a little,
almost a little too much,
which is one of the Canadian should loss.
Yeah.
The little bit of the Rhonda Syndrome,
they're little bit,
well,
I don't know if it's that,
but you know,
she was definitely doing a lot of press and a lot of fucking tremendous amount
of pressure,
but I'll tell you what,
dude,
when she was talking to the camera and she was talking to rose and she's like
the Boogie woman coming for you.
Who you women come in for you.
I can fucking do scared.
I was legitimately the greatest like promo all time.
I was like,
Boogie woman.
What the Fuck I did?
When you see her looking at rose in her eyes,
like staring into your soul and she's talking all kinds of crazy shit,
I'm going to fuck you up.
I'm going to hurt you.
And rose is saying the Lord's prayer at some demonic shit.
I was like,
why?
I asked rose.
They're already saying.
She's like,
I was saying the Lord's prayer and she didn't even look at you.
Anybody.
She wouldn't look okay.
I was like,
all right.
I'm like,
wow,
this is for Rico.
Yes.
Easy to say.
In retrospect.
I knew then something special was going to happen.
Hell No.
I thought real.
I was like,
Roseney see a psychiatrist.
That's why when I saw that way and I'm like,
we need to get rose some help.
Pace up forever.
I'm like,
you know what?
We need some professional help.
But after the fact,
knowing the result that rose won by knockout,
it makes it even all the more profound.
Now you can see motherfuckers just reciting the you want to talk about,
I hope the UFC realizes and I think they do.
That's a fucking star.
That's rose real stone.
Hell yeah.
No real stars.
The look,
she's a skinny five years old.
She's got the look.
She shaves her head.
She's a beautiful stranger.
Sing Lucas
that 11 Lucas.
So in she's 12 she's 12 she's 11.0 she's,
yeah,
and she's like a genuinely good person.
Like when she was talking after the fight,
she's like,
just child beating.
Just be nice to each other.
Here's the thing Joe,
that's really coming from the fans gravitate towards that nice person.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
When you look like her and you weigh 115 pounds,
you're a woman.
You fuck up the Bogie.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
I'll guarantee you man,
if,
if she doesn't become as big as star as any other woman in MMA,
I would be stunned.
Damn,
that'd be stylized position.
Cause she's a good person.
She's worked hard.
Misha Tate got some star out of it.
Rhonda clearly got the biggest right for sure.
Rhonda got the biggest by far.
She was the biggest like as far as timing,
it was her insane domination or sure opponents just weren't on our level until
they were right.
So until she fought Holly,
they weren't really on our level.
And she also had this new thing,
which was the female ass kicker,
this thing that didn't exist before.
So in that way,
like one of the most unique athletes ever besides Ali and,
uh,
who the coal miner's daughter,
Christy Martin member,
Christy Martin from back in the old Tyson fights fight on the undercard,
the coal miner's daughter.
Remember that?
Sure.
But they're pioneers,
but it's different.
Yeah.
Not that much.
Like Laila Ali got few people paying attention to better be able to batch your
dad's Muhammad Ali for God.
What the fuck that mean?
It's a shoe in.
Yeah,
man.
But being George Lucas,
his daughter,
like you're going to be,
you know,
in star wars we're fucked.
Yeah.
But it just never,
it never hit the levels that it hit with Rhonda.
No.
Right.
But I think that it's possible that rose could be the biggest star in MMA today.
I've really think so.
I don't think anyone's ever going to be a Rhonda,
because that was a,
the first one,
you know,
it was crazy.
Yeah,
I agree.
But rose could be gigantic.
I mean,
I really think she,
who knows if she could be as big as Rhonda,
but she could be gigantic.
I really think so.
Yeah.
I like that she's true to herself.
She's fucking robot you'll to do.
She does wild shit.
She throws up arm bars.
I mean she,
she does wild shit.
That fucking karate hottie fight,
which she had kicked her and choked her out.
Dude,
she's a little savage.
She keeps on your back.
Ooh.
The thing that,
that division is kind of stacked though.
Like you want to do a lot of people,
but for rose there's a lot of tough competition is very tough.
Competition is tough competition standing up too.
There's a lot of good strikers in that division case scenario though,
especially for the USC and rose,
cause I'm,
you know rose,
my favorite friend and that division come from Denver.
But you know that that division for her to defend it and build a star like the
head and Yolanda,
that's when you get a star.
But if that belt circulating,
it's,
we get,
the public doesn't gravitate towards that.
We don't like that.
And you know,
she's likely going to have to fight Karolina who went five hard rounds with you,
Ana and three rounds with her.
Was it three or five rounds with her?
Which she wanted a decision.
It was a three,
right?
I think it was three.
There's just go on drudge.
Jessica drives a monstrous fight with Claudia.
Good Dasia Jessica drudge beat the shit out of claw.
You get,
Hey.
Yeah.
She beat the brakes off shit out of her.
That was the man handling.
Nope.
No offense.
Whoa man.
Handling.
She will manhandled her.
She,
she strong strong arms.
She's sheets smash.
She hulk smashed.
She straight up.
Hulk smash.
Straight up.
I was like,
Jesus Christ man.
He's only seen an ass whooping like that since cyber got ahold of some bitch.
Didn't we wash that one live?
Did we do a fight companion for that?
Did we?
I don't think we did cause I'm huge.
Claudia Fan.
I think she's so hot.
Yeah,
she's very pretty right.
Yeah.
She's taken a break though.
Well,
you know what man,
the Bonnie only has so many wars in it too.
She couldn't,
that there was a lot of people were talking about with the Alana,
they're thinking about you on or like think about your monitoring.
In fact though.
But before the fact,
before the fact,
there was some discussion we're talking about,
look,
I didn't think that rose was going to do that.
No,
fuck.
Oh,
I'm just going to get I bet on it.
Yeah,
I did.
I did that on rose.
Good.
Well she's such a big underdog.
Four to one uh,
shit.
She was plus I think I get it.
Plus 500 I posted it,
whatever it was.
I got $500 on her one.
I forget how much to grant them,
but that's nice.
Yeah.
Just because rose,
she has that x factor where she's just explode for for a while,
for a female fighter.
Yet she's wild.
But it's hard to train for and you know,
at the beginning of the fight,
you know you want it.
She had done nothing to wanna all you'll know one would get in her face.
She put her fist out,
touch her fist with her face.
You know,
you wanna was really trying to get in her head and the whole time roads going
off,
father who art in heaven,
hallowed some scary shit.
Scary Shit.
But when the actual face down came phase down,
when they're standing in front of each other and they were about to fight,
you want to talk and all the crazy shit and she got close to her.
Rose pushed her away.
She's like,
bitch,
get the fuck outta here.
And that's,
and that's when he,
that's when he got dirt and she did work.
What the fuck she do on landed up punch.
She lands like [inaudible].
She's like Ugh,
but rose open strong with a leg kick.
And I was like,
oh Jesus.
And then she threw that leap and Hook Dick.
Trevor Whitman is a bad motherfucker.
Well when you have Trevor Whitman,
yeah,
he is a fun is a mastermind.
Phenomenal Strike Vm.
A focus on one fighter.
He's a mass.
Justin is rose Carwyn.
Nate more card come on just to fly flight in Denver just to work on his jab.
Just gagey training now with,
think about,
think about this fight that he's got with Eddie Alverez.
Trending now for Eddie offers gauge is what is this fucking record?
It's something insane.
20 [inaudible] or something like that.
G A t.
H,
you know,
I was suppose to him,
he's got an insane record.
He'd been in mopping the floor with those c level c level fighters in the world
series,
but still is fun.
Still the Michael Johnson 14 and 18 and,
oh look at that one.
Submission to decisions.
15 knockouts.
But Damn,
I know Trevor,
when when gay t fight sometimes technique goes out the window and goes animal.
Fuck it dude.
He's,
which is why being a level he's wild is shit that Michael Johnson fight showed
that Michael Johnson hurt him,
you know,
tagged him hard and he came back and smashed him.
Eddie Alvarez fight.
It's through great fight.
Fuck yeah.
It's a great fight because people forget but gave g his background
is wrestling.
Yeah.
He was amazing.
Rest at University of Northern Colorado.
Freak athletic freak vision is awful too.
He squints he has those classes all the time.
I'm like pro,
oh fuck.
Let me get that fixed.
I don't think you can get lasik and fight the commissioner's.
Dot.
You.
They don't,
they don't let you do Lasik,
but it'll day you could do the other kinds.
Pr.
I don't know.
PD,
I want to say.
I almost said PDK like there's two different kinds.
There's like [inaudible] something like that.
The other kinds of we'll use a scalpel.
Yeah.
The one that they use a scalpel apparently they can do,
that's the Russian shit.
That's what I had done,
I think.
Yeah.
What was wrong with your vision?
Uh,
I'd have contacts and glasses.
I've seen guys fight with those and they lose a contact and they drop it and
then they got to keep fighting and now you're like one eye's kid.
NC State with soft contacts in your eyeballs out.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
I got lasik after I was playing Lacrosse game and I was zoning out and I was in
Denver and it's cold and like contact froze and like you're in.
I was like,
now I was like,
oh fuck.
And then someone to hit me and it shattered in my eye.
Oh Jesus Christ you to hard contact.
Yeah.
Hard one.
Oh my God.
What'd you get hit with a ball or a stick?
I think some do just lit me up or something.
My fucking context fucking shredded.
And I was like,
I need to unplanned,
you know,
sports or man,
I can fucking content.
I used to always freak me out about classes.
Like if someone got punched with glasses on,
the glass went into their eyes.
I mean,
well they used to have those thick gastroenteritis thick as like athletic ones.
My poor brother used to wear those can use Kurt Rambis or some shit.
Even those though.
What if those things break their show fucking thick?
Like at the there what like,
uh,
the president's windows are made.
Oh,
you can make it like out of a,
like a plexiglass today.
It doesn't necessarily have to be glasses in classes,
like a thick,
thick plastic.
So really can't bring a super nerdy,
no chips when he wear that thing.
So it's funny to me when basketball players can look like a broken nose or
something like that.
And then forever they have this fucking mask on too much,
right?
Yeah.
Too much.
What's the leak?
Is what we see for the next few weeks too.
Well,
it's,
well,
it's crazy.
It's like this dude.
Oh,
come on ma.
Carbon fiber too.
I love it.
Lebron James had one of those.
A lot of people have had it,
but did Lebron where because of an injury or did you were just to be a beast?
No,
you can't wear that shit.
Give me a close up on that.
It does what?
Kimmy?
That's insane.
It's carbon fiber.
No,
I love it.
It does.
The one right now.
I want to wear one.
Just black go out.
Shit goes down.
The nose is such a terrible design.
I know you had your nose fixed after the Cro cop fight.
God.
But I just see so many people get their no smashed like the,
they had a close up of cowboys.
Oh,
Kobe had one too.
Huh?
Almost everyone's had one cause they all hurt their nose.
That's it's like Zorro than it's pretty bad ass.
It does look pretty bad ass.
But seriously,
I want one too though.
Bitch ass shit.
If you think about all this stuff that fighters go through,
come on.
Cody's Cody's was rough.
Let me,
uh,
capitalist cowboys rough Darren till caught him with that elbow.
That fucking
snapping down elbow.
I know.
We did the fight companion for that one.
I know I told you dude,
Vinny shoreman would not stop raving about Darren till he would not stop raving
before the fight.
And shoreman knows his shit.
He was like,
Ma,
I've never seen anything like it for the kids going to be a champion.
Yeah.
Most people from Liverpool,
he doesn't have to fight lined up,
but I'm surprised he wants to play Wonderboy blogs.
Watch the shit out of,
watch this shit.
Oh,
I wouldn't mind till verse Colby.
Let this young lions kill each other.
You know what I'm saying?
Like why not?
Yeah.
But if you're a fan of high level striking,
you tell me Wonderboy versus Darrin tail wouldn't be insane to watch it all.
God watch this shit.
If I'm Wonderboy though,
I'm like,
come on,
take that fucking monster.
And what does e seven old man and he's,
he just be schmozzle doll.
He shoots,
he's enormous deals.
A big no,
no one tried to fight some big,
the only get wants to find me with like,
uh,
Mike Perry,
Mike planting the parents to find him,
but he only a huge fight coming up.
He's fine ponds and that Lbo you've got to concentrate on and obi definitely not
a consequence.
Jump Pato over.
How about your boy?
Johnny Hendricks was like,
I figured it out.
I'm going to Jackson's let me try this out.
[inaudible] your son.
Yeah,
he fought the fucking eraser.
Dude.
That guy's scary.
Even Post Usada scary.
Hold up.
Erase or listen to me right now that golden snitches good.
Better.
I don't know what all they did all these years being figured out.
I've got to figure it out.
I looked at his body,
I thought,
what the fuck dude,
he's so jack.
He's jacked in shape.
Good luck.
Might be the best looking dude in the UFC so we can do it on the planet.
He's straight up.
I didn't want to come off as gay with his shirt off.
If it particular,
she's too aggressive there,
but they're doing the post fight a showdown.
I'm like,
I bet he slammed all the green card girls if you wanted to.
As he was talking,
I'm like,
this dude is just slang dick out.
Get it right there.
When he was standing next to a giant shakers at the way,
and so I was like,
no,
Johnny,
I'm not a middle weight.
This is,
this is a middle weight.
This is a big middle.
May his soul look how much bigger he is in Johnny.
I mean,
and she shreds
and the fight was basically an assault.
It was an assault.
You would never believe that Johnny Hendricks was a former world champion of you
saw the way the eraser beat the shit out of him.
I mean,
he just beat the shit out of them.
Johnny fire back.
I mean,
he's tough.
He tried through some leg kicks,
threw some punches,
but he was just getting fucking destroyed and just walked down and smashed,
kick to the body over and over again.
He was wincing after the first kick blind nomez second kick to the body.
He got hit with you.
See wincing.
And here was when he clipped Johnny Hendricks.
I mean it was no contest,
unfortunately for Johnny and that the flight,
if you,
if you want to faint,
just looked in there like,
oh he got got out of the crowd to fight this dime piece.
Like look at that.
Oh this guy who likes to drink beers fighting this diode piece,
Brazilian well might be the best league in Brazilian of all time.
By the way,
Johnny is just not the same guy.
He's just not the same guy.
And you could speculate all day.
That's why,
you know what I'm saying?
Like you're like,
I think sometimes people halon guys for what they've done lately,
but for Johnny Hendricks,
I mean you've had a great career.
Brother had a great career,
but some time in a weight class above I should be.
I agree.
Cause he doesn't want to watch his diet.
I think it's a number of things,
but you know,
I just,
man,
there's nothing to hang your head on.
You got to your world champion,
man.
Yeah.
You know,
a lot of people think you'd beat GSP.
Like you've had a great fucking crime man.
A lot of people,
a lot of people.
And now a good argument to that could really,
you could really have a real,
I mean if you were just objective,
he didn't have a dog in the fight,
you could have a real interesting conversation about who won that function
argument there.
Sure.
And I,
and I think if you're Johnny,
you know,
and he's probably taken a lot of abuse online and I wish you would stop,
but it's all good man.
You've had a good go.
I hope he doesn't take abuse.
Really what we should do,
we should be praising heaps on Paula Kosta cause that guy's scary.
He's fucking terrifying.
That guy's the future.
He's a legit as fuck around.
But yeah.
Well who knows.
I would like to see someone test him.
I'd like to see him again.
So like a real strong hundred 85 pound wrestler.
I think he's four known UCA and all knockouts for three.
You all knockouts is last two.
He merch dudes.
So what we got to see his,
he's for real and he's a future.
How's he know how much of a Gq or some shit,
I'm telling you,
man,
I'm fucking,
when I was watching I was like,
what the fuck?
Well,
that could be the one thing that doesn't mean Weinstein next to him.
Fucking,
I mean,
good looking dude,
man.
Maybe that could be,
what does a man just,
Oh,
just young pussy.
When you're that good looking,
it's probably,
it's gotta be hard.
It's got to be hard to say no super hard.
And as he gets more and more famous,
you know it's going to be famous for sure.
For sure.
It keeps smashing people that way.
Looking that way.
Smashing people that way.
That's trial.
Both son,
if he's not famous,
he should sue the UFC.
You'll look at this face,
Shit.
Fuck him on the front cover of the WII video game for gut.
They useless fucks.
It just,
Johnny looked two weight classes lighter than them.
Johnny looked like he was a welterweight and uh,
the eraser looked like he was a light.
Johnny's just lost men and like go into Jacqueline's and I'm not knocking
Jackson Jackson,
one of the greatest capital all the time still is.
But when fighters go there because they've seen how much success they've had,
it's literally heaven's waiting room.
It's the fucking,
you know,
it's the Florida of fighting camps.
The tread serve.
Yeah,
here's a solution step.
But if you're going there,
it's probably not the answer.
What's also,
you gotta think the years that he wasn't there and those play a factor in its
development.
It's not like you just get right back to where he should have been like,
oh,
here's the answer.
No,
you were training wrong for all these years.
And it's performance dwindled pretty substantially except for the one fight with
Hector Lombard that's,
which is really interesting.
That was like the one fight where a,
he actually looked pretty good.
Yeah,
he did.
And he beat Lombard.
You know,
who's still fucking dangerous?
And I was like,
look,
Johnny Hendricks looks like he's back.
And that wasn't that long ago.
Hell knows last year.
But there was another guy who shouldn't be at 185 pounds.
So he fought a guy who's like him,
a thick dude who's really a one 70 that doesn't have the best diet in the world.
I don't care what anybody says.
You know that you shouldn't be criticizing him.
You shouldn't.
You know,
you don't walk a mile in his shoes and you know,
maybe his body doesn't want to respond and cutting down to one 70 anymore.
Stop.
Just be honest.
And I'm a Johnny Hendrix Fan.
Look at his body.
You should not be fighting the best professional fighters in the world unless
you're a heavyweight and you have a body like that with all that extra body fat
that does you no good.
It's not aiding your performance in any way,
shape,
or form.
It is 100% a sign of a lack of either planning.
We didn't plan your diet out in advance where you're too heavy or too much body
fat coming into camp or poor discipline or poor organization of your diet where
you don't understand like what foods you should and shouldn't be eating.
When a guy's training for a three round fucking fight at the top of the heap in
the UFC middleweight division,
you've got to think this guy has got to be doing some goddamn rigorous shit.
The American public,
if they're watching this going,
if this fucking guy can't look good,
how am I going to look good?
And I'm not,
I'm kind of exaggerating because Johnny didn't look terrible,
but like I think it was worse,
cause hopefully look great coastal elite statute and we don't all have to look
like a bodybuilder where some of the toughest guys like Evan Dunham,
he doesn't have a bodybuilder physique,
but he's not,
he doesn't have any extra weight on them.
That extra weight is not doing you any good.
[inaudible] boys not willing to need yeah.
Events,
you know,
bodybuilding of it,
but he doesn't have a fucking extra pound on them.
You know north,
there's Woodley Willie's fucking shredded,
he's got the best body and the division Woodley could win the Olympia,
he could win Mr Lily's top five just January.
Just got into it 100% he's got phenomenal genetics,
but anyway he's not,
you can't be competing at the highest levels of the sport given up that much of
an advance.
Like if that was a good agreement that you had like all right,
we could fight a one 85 but you have to be 20% body fat and I could be 10 like
what?
Especially this day and age,
like mixed martial arts to such a high levels like do.
I was just going over the,
the welterweights the other day and I'm like,
Holy Shit,
Holy Shit.
There's so much talent.
Like the UFC in the welterweight division is such good hands.
There's so much young killing talent.
If you're not taking every advantage of the the techniques and you're training,
you're left in the dust.
And Jonny is from that old school kind of training.
You know what I'm saying?
Like he's an older cat man.
Well what he was talking about when he was talking about training in Texas that
he couldn't spar hard with people or they wouldn't come back,
that he had to like take it light on them.
And then what he really loved about going to Jackson's,
he was dealing with a real high level fighters all the time.
So he's getting great training in which I fought,
was great to hear,
but it's not great that he spent so much time doing it the other way.
I don't know,
2017 you lose your,
you lose your focus,
you lose the drive and you just start going through the motions if you're not
being challenged all the time.
And he was obviously being challenged in competition,
but he should have been
with a real camp a long time ago.
The great,
what happened with him,
he had some,
he was with team take down,
they had some sort of a well did agreement.
So he was a team take down,
he came from Oklahoma state,
right,
national champion,
whatever,
70 time,
all American,
just a monster.
And then the deal was,
is there going to support them financially with,
you know,
a house,
food training camp.
They take care of all that and give you like a salary salary,
but once you make it or we're taking 50% of everything and when you're young up
and coming hungry fighter like that's a great deal.
Until you become Johnny Hendricks and become the world champion,
like hold up 50% I appreciate what you guys did for him,
but God damn man,
like you're rob me blind here.
This is crazy.
So he had to go separate ways.
Here's the question then.
A big rig steakhouse did Dave,
that was a terrible idea.
I would eat there though.
Did they?
I would eat there just for the story or the room.
That should be a selfie while hold off the menu.
But I'll hate on it if it was a good job.
You leave a Yelp review like pro tip.
Have you ever Yelp reviews?
I've never have you ever.
That's why we're friends.
Have you ever,
have you ever,
have you ever blessed the comment on Youtube?
Nope.
That's why we're friends.
Have you ever hated on a guy on Instagram?
I don't think so.
No.
Me Neither.
No,
not really.
My style.
No.
It's waste of time.
Yet my friends don't do that.
I don't have any friends that I don't get young.
Who the fuck you gonna to do?
There's only so much time in this world.
You should use choose to use it wisely.
I was doing a mls show.
Some guy asked me a question,
stood up and goes,
hey man,
have you read the Youtube comments?
I won't stop there.
I've never read a youtube comment in my laugh.
My man,
so there's no court.
He goes,
really?
Never went.
Not once.
I'm too busy creating material for you guys.
I'm not reading comments.
Man was like,
all right.
No doubt he's trying to rights.
He's trying to tell you something.
He wrote some shit.
Really mean probably,
probably trolling.
Probably.
Maybe he felt that he was friendly with it.
Hopefully not.
Um,
we're not hating on a garlic.
Johnny.
I love John.
Like I said,
there's,
there's no reason it is reality right now.
Look,
we sound like we're saying this and he looks like,
you know,
like Paula Kosta.
Yes.
Sometimes I think people confuse hate and,
and being a critical of a,
of a performance or reality.
Yeah.
But,
but also like when,
when they go,
you're hating on the UFC,
the UFC sometimes we talked about pay per view numbers or the last papers,
and I'm like,
listen,
I have nothing to do with the way they promote the fighters,
all that stuff.
If the numbers are low,
I literally have nothing to do with that.
I just give my thoughts on what is going on in the landscape of the UFC.
Hey,
pull up.
That's actually eating.
Pull up a picture of Johnny Hendricks with a beer in his hand with his shirt
off.
He's got a picture where his gut is enormous.
It's used to be about two 25 yeah.
Between five to get up to 25 that you can do.
You just can't do that.
And he could do that.
And because he was the champ,
you know,
at the time,
a while ago was a long time ago.
This Day and age,
right?
The game's evolving so fucking fast as a welterweight man.
You better have your shit together.
I was looking division.
How scared for people?
Yeah.
Name off.
I'll use baby training right now.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a series shark tank and it's a good combination of upcoming new guys and
ventral.
Yeah.
There's an awesome just combination of everybody in there.
There's one,
but there's a better one.
We see him from the side.
Yeah,
above it.
Right above it.
With the hat on.
Look at this one.
What?
That's whatever.
Go to the one with the red shirt.
That's incredible.
I don't give a fuck.
Wait a minute.
Is that real?
That's,
that's real.
How could that be real?
There's no way he ever got that bag.
Is there,
come on.
He likes to eat,
Bro.
What?
He had biceps surgeon and said,
fuck it.
What year was this though?
Last week?
2014 oh,
he had bicep surgery three years ago.
Dude,
that'll,
that'll take you back a year.
Right by itself.
That probably,
uh oh his arm.
Oh,
okay.
What did he eat?
Rocks.
Meat.
They inject into his arm,
his under his stomach,
you know?
Yeah.
Again,
I love Johnny and we're not hating on Johnny.
No,
you just,
it,
there's just no room for anything other than excellence at one 70 now or even
one 85 now.
But,
but also for killer for the sport and where it's evolved that,
you know,
you're in the NFL,
you can't get away with that.
And the NBA,
he can't get away with that.
The UFC is getting there at a high level where maybe you better have all your
bases covered,
getting lit the fuck up.
These certainly classes.
Dude.
How about o s p
takes a fight on 11 days notice.
It was like,
yeah,
I'll do it.
Hey Oof.
Crazy head kick.
And he landed a head kick earlier in the fight.
Same kick and we were talking about a two.
We're like,
look out for his left kick.
He's got a brutal left kick and then boom,
right on the button.
Walk away home,
man.
I mean,
it was crazy.
It was so powerful that God,
Doug just walked away out cold,
just out cold.
He silently on this,
a little bit of a rampage at two oh five two you know he has three von flue
chokes.
Yes.
Crazy man.
Cause he's not a Jujitsu guy.
There's only been training with this or even five on flue chokes ever.
He's got three of them look up prior to that baseball bat against the head.
So dude and bright on the jaw to great win.
Yeah.
And it was a good fight up until then.
You know the head turn,
turn corners doing well especially with his wrestling.
Yeah.
But then Osb,
just so explosive man.
Jamie just wants to keep it from showing it to him.
Poor get toward Croix man.
Poor Cory.
Yeah.
That's a rough way to go out.
The whole card was insane.
Right.
That may for me as far as the surprises,
three three titles on the line.
Yeah,
just the best UFC of all time and GSP going.
Like when he clipped him with that left hand,
going to the ground,
ground and pound and then go into the rear naked choke.
And then pulling them asleep.
I gotta be honest.
I'm surprised Bisbing net retire with you after the fight.
Yeah.
I feel like we're still gonna go.
I'm like,
well what are you gonna do?
It's gonna fight somebody else.
Who?
Yo Romero.
Don Da Don da Don Danta.
You'll just waiting back there.
Bisping Beats Yoel Romero.
They will light England on fire.
God dammit.
They have that fight in London.
I mean,
think about it.
Michael got choked unconscious.
He got dropped with a good left hand,
but he didn't get knocked out.
He also wasn't around.
Yeah,
he won the second round.
But what I'm saying is he didn't take the kind of damage where it has to be out
for a year,
you know?
No,
hell no.
Hell No.
He get up.
He could fight March for sure.
So if they're going to do one in London,
Yoel Romero,
I think there was a fight in March and like bom,
Bom,
bom,
that'd be sick.
Yo,
y'all were marrow was everywhere with Jorge Mas doll when they were really,
they were running into each other and there was a video of Mazda doll going at
it with Michael Biz.
I saw that and they,
everybody gets separated,
but Yo Romero is right there in the mix.
He there.
Mike will be speaking today.
Have to make that happen,
dude.
Just off the fucking,
yeah,
look,
they're hanging out together.
Hi right here.
I'll tell you what,
if your Bisbing I,
I love busy and there's,
he's as tough as they come.
I don't want to be alone with total two motherfuckers.
Hell knows what's,
you have to burning the flag or whatever.
You Go.
What did he do?
Did he burn the flag?
Did he brought a Brazilian?
Ripped it.
He threw it at him during the fight.
That's already like Dave Chappelle stomped it.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
Yeah,
definitely don't do that.
How bad ass is fucking Robert Whitaker that he went five rounds that dude and
wanted decision.
I know.
And he did it with a fucked up knee.
He got his neat generally army to fight.
What are your scary,
no one's trying to fight Whitaker.
Hemet.
Him versus GSP is Yikes,
but that ain't happening.
You don't need to be scared.
That ain't happening.
You don't kick shock array like,
Yo,
this DC.
He's just be like,
Nah,
I'm good on that,
bro.
I don't know about that.
I'm telling you old former welterweight,
it's not happening,
son.
[inaudible] a beast,
man.
He's so fascinating.
Explosive,
and he's young as fuck.
I think Robert's only 26 or 27
if you guessed,
take yes,
I say 27
26 that's youngest files as the
primer.
20th he's not even in his prime yet.
Dude.
This is what if you had a gun to my head right now,
like get what's next?
What's next?
I'd say Whitaker.
Rockhold in Australia.
That's what you're getting
and then you get GSP Woodley.
I'd love that.
Dana White,
George Saint Pierre staying 185 pounds facing Robert Whitaker next.
Holy Shit,
Leah.
My face.
You don't believe it.
I don't think you know shit.
How about that?
Down to call Dana white right now.
Tell him Dan I,
but it says you're alive.
Totally little kid shit.
[inaudible] I was saying
I'll believe it when I see it.
That's all I said.
I believe I just said,
you said a lot of shit.
Nah,
like the like it's the UFC his best year ever.
Maybe know some shit.
We don't know.
Yeah,
that's crazy talk.
But I don't have to be the UFC accountant to just run through some numbers in my
old brain brain here that might have some brain trauma and go,
ah,
I don't think so.
There's some awesome things that happened.
Some awesome fights for sure.
There's one awesome manaca fight.
Yeah.
But I'm saying there's been,
well,
if you would just want to look at the business overall.
Yes,
no.
For pay per view sales,
yes.
But for people like you and I that are just fans.
Oh,
it's been,
it's been one of the best years ever.
God,
really?
Yeah.
That's mighty mouse.
Mighty mouse beating the title and then doing it the way he did slam the school
and get a flying arm bar.
Cool.
Establishing dominance like that Amanda Nunez and Rhonda rousing was that way.
She wasn't all,
that was last year.
That was last December,
I believe it was in January.
This here,
Bro,
it was last year.
Am I going crazy?
I'm pretty sure it was last December.
You might be right this year.
They haven't had Connor,
Rhonda Brock.
They haven't had their heavyweights.
Uh,
December 29th,
Bal clubbed.
Very,
very cool.
Yeah,
I guess that's not this year does it?
Uh,
yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Like it's been a down year as far as there's been some fun matchups if you're
balls deep into MMA like we are,
but as far as just like a great year,
no,
no.
There were some,
some of those paper views.
I was like,
God damn.
What are the fight nights like?
Come on man.
I think there's just a transitional period.
And again,
it's not the UFC his fault,
it's with the talent to,
it just wasn't timing up.
Right.
But then you get certain cards like this where they hit it out the fucking park.
Yeah.
This one was so epic.
[inaudible] was told Cody and Dominick Cruz's here,
or last year,
Cody,
uh,
Dominick Cruz was this year.
Yeah.
So there's that.
Cody.
Dominick Cruz was a big fight,
especially for fans.
What about 55 now it's all stalled out because with Habib on the sidelines,
Tony Ferguson being the interim interim champion had to wait forever.
I mean,
do we even know if he was going to fight against fight Barboza December 30th
that is definitely happened.
Oh,
they said no more Tiramisu,
sir.
You're fine.
December 30th yeah.
Daniel Cormay said he has a real nutritionist now.
Okay.
What the fuck does that happen?
Oh,
do you?
You rank number one in the world.
Did you get a new tradition on demand smashing and you almost died from making
weight and someone was like,
Oh man,
you know what we should do and twice almost died twice.
You keep missing weight,
Bro.
No,
you could be the best in the world.
We should hire a nutritionist.
It's not a bad idea
if you're listening.
He's a devout Muslim,
so like anytime it's anywhere near Ramadan,
can't fight.
Well,
some guys pulled it out below.
Muhammad did.
He did.
He did it by organizing his camp.
He organized all of his training.
So all of his training was done after dark because that fast all during the day.
Right.
And you can get once who?
Sundown.
Yeah.
I think,
I don't know even know if you're allowed to drink water.
No,
I don't think so.
But you just go crazy once the sun goes down,
Sun's down,
sunrise to sunset,
you go nuts.
So I think what he did was just alters training and train at night.
I guess it could be how bad you want it.
Well,
it's just such a crazy rule.
Like if God was around,
would he really decided like when,
I guess the idea is that you're by recognizing that you're doing something
difficult that you don't want to do.
You're like,
uh,
in this religious tradition,
you're honoring him.
Fuck about your internal fight in UFC might.
But either way it could be get your shit together,
something and let you fight.
Yes.
You broke my heart when he pulled out of the Tony Ferguson fight.
That broke my heart too.
So mad day of the weigh ins.
I was so mad.
There's no way.
I know.
I'm never did before the weigh ins or was it the day of or day before?
Very close.
Within a day or two,
very close,
whatever the day of it was so frustrated.
He can't say anything now.
He's got to just be completely quiet and you just go wins.
Yeah.
And Barboza is that,
you know,
it's not,
it's a tough fight for him because Barboza is the nastiest stand up in the game,
especially at division.
But yeah,
it's a winnable fight for QB.
He gets a hold of you.
You're going for a ride.
Yeah.
If he gets a hold of you,
he can wrestle.
Fuck you.
Look,
no one else could be Tony.
That's the fight,
isn't it?
But you,
I mean obviously you got Tony.
Conor I think happens in March,
but when he was holding Michael Johnson down helpless and just beating the shit
out of him that he was helpless.
When,
when have you ever seen anybody be able to do that?
She was talking to him and goes,
just give up.
I need this.
Just stop now.
I don't want to do this.
Woman does out beating the shit out of him.
I mean complete total control of him.
How he's beating the shit out of shit.
What's crazy about it is like there is at that level,
it's very rare that that can happen at that level where someone is so much
better that the other person just completely tied up there.
You go there on a car and to look at that card,
man.
Um,
the Eagle hold up.
They don't have a main of Carlos condit returning against Neil Magni come on
kids.
Oh Shit.
Magnet cat.
They're throwing magnet just to the the killers.
I like how they say to be determined for the main event because they're banking
on Conner.
Well,
who knows?
Who knows?
I'm gonna cruise versus Rivera's.
Interesting.
Hell yeah.
V Little versus Carlos boss.
I was very interested in via your next star in the women's division.
You're going over last.
You got fucking round tree verse Saki.
Goca
that's interested.
The UFC is tweet pissed
me off with that.
[inaudible] is a fucking monster.
He's a monster.
No,
they ain't answer that.
Put stand dot n.
Dot.
Bay.
I was like,
ah.
Who's running rose.
What?
14 year old from bread.
It's running this thing.
Yeah.
I read that.
I'm like,
Whoa,
man.
Do Better.
And how about Camaro Ooze Mon versus meek loose month.
The guy,
everyone's scared.
So Uzma and wanted to fight to ooze months.
Another one at one 70 that's terrifying.
Yes.
We could be a world champ.
Nigerian nightmare.
He's a nightmare.
Christian.
[inaudible] shout out fucking dude a meal.
Meek is a beast.
It looks like he's just scary.
Fuck too,
man.
It's all very interesting.
No one wants to buy deuce mine.
They tried off around the fights and meek was the only guy a ticket.
I'll fight him.
Let's meet that now is make us straight fucking viking.
What's going on this fall?
I'm Vikki genes.
Tell you what would that bodies challenging our boy zillion time.
He smashed Tokyo.
He fought who somehow apar Harris and just knocked him unconscious.
That's right.
That's how he got into the UFC.
He's a beast,
man.
That's a real good fight.
But I just don't know.
You know,
I don't know if a meal meek is going to be fast enough to keep it smile.
Oh,
no one's if I do smile.
Oh No.
He said you're lying.
He's The scariest number 12 rank guy in the world.
How about Huseman versus Darren tail?
Jay's I,
he was on Colby Colby tills.
What?
I'd like,
I like [inaudible] versus anybody.
I would,
I like to see,
oh,
spawn fight for the title.
I like to see him hurt anybody.
I really think right now.
Yep.
I think he's the most underrated guy in,
in maybe in every division.
That's what I think.
Know How people fear.
I don't know if I'd want to see him fight for the title.
Right.
Who was his last fight?
Click on that.
There's just destroying dudes.
Yeah.
Destroying dudes.
Was his last fight.
Surgery or Mris?
Oh yeah.
Sergio Mars does Jujitsu Guy.
Yo,
he'd put the smash on him.
Morris is a Badass Jujitsu player.
He's the first guy that a tap,
chron and chron got his black belt.
Fucking gave Neil Magni that horrible triangle and present.
That's right.
I need you to do not go together.
Especially that guy's Jujitsu.
When he fought in the finals,
when Sergio Front in the finals of the ultimate fighter,
it was in Brazil.
Uh,
he,
he goes,
my opponent has just as much of a chance of getting me pregnant as he does
submitting me.
Jesus Christ.
It's a great line.
He was fighting,
saves her for her hair.
She's Oh,
well who's a monster?
Yeah,
Nate's fight.
Nate.
Yeah,
I was going to say that.
Yeah.
Brian was at Aka jacking off the boys at Ak and guys did jack off.
Uh,
I know Luke Rockhold get him a facial for the most part.
So Luke's too.
Yeah.
Luke's there.
And uh,
Cowen was saying,
um,
we're,
we're talking about listen,
train of thought,
talking about,
thinking about killing Jack and how many guys he jacked off at Aka no.
Oh,
he saw Nate Nate strain at AK now.
Mark Waters.
Yes.
No Shit.
Yeah,
he's doing a lot of his camp there.
That's interesting.
I'm motherfuckers been fighting since he was 12.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Right.
Think about how many wars archives,
but then remember his fight with Woodley and strike force.
We knocked him out with a mortal Kombat combination.
Ab Ab left right CV,
find a Nate Marquardt Kaos Tyron Woodley.
They became world champion.
Yeah.
People forget is multi bankers champion.
But that was like his first real,
no,
not that Pinker's wasn't real,
but that was his first huge bellman.
Strikeforce.
Yeah.
Super talented.
Super Young Elbow.
Boom.
I mean,
come on man.
It was crazy about that.
That camp is working on this weird like taekwondo gun.
They're just doing elbows and we'd make fun of him.
He'd be in the corner just in like these weird fucking motions.
Right.
Okay.
Naked luck with that.
I mean,
well that's what he uses as well,
dude.
Elbows.
I mean you gotta think how about Bisbee on the ground on the bottom.
Those Evelyn [inaudible] lit his face up,
tore it up,
caught him up bad.
He was bleeding badly.
Like he was having a hard time seeing it and you could see it on his forehead.
He was Kinda on his bridgers knows it's good.
Elbows are like some of the most under utilized weapons.
You got to think of the,
the,
the surface area.
You can get a hard striking in a very close quarters with elbows.
Like when someone's very good with it.
You remember when Cro cop fought Gonzaga?
Oh my God.
Top of him and just opened him up like,
like he hit him with an ax.
I have word
woo woo
lamb,
like watching good movie tie to watching people that are good at elbows and
smash.
Slash.
Elbows.
Elbows are tough because you can't really train elbows.
Oh,
that was the other fight.
Did you see the fight and the fight pass?
Undercard which ween watch rapists for us to hobbies,
brother.
No,
I heard for us rob,
he's a brother.
Just got dealt due to bad by two.
I didn't see it,
dude.
He,
it was bad and I saw it coming cause he was giving up the spin.
I saw him like he's going to spin and he spun and hit him with a spinning elbow
on the jaw.
Snow snapped his head around like,
like you've never seen West for us,
like unconscious,
fully unconscious for five,
10 minutes.
Fully unconscious damn than I [inaudible].
She has still traveling yet a huge main event.
You had to get ready for my man.
Let's get back in this brother.
It's going to shake that off and it was a really good fight and his brother was
put in a tremendous amount of pressure on the other guy.
God Damn it.
I forget his name.
Do you not have the highlight?
Jamie can be tough with the fight path.
Huh?
It's out there.
What is a homeboy's name?
Watch Ricardo Lamas Ramos
it.
It's a headline on that was really weird.
I'm just gonna pull up the videos.
Let me see if this is it.
Yeah,
that's it right here.
Boom.
Oh.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
There are days goes.
He goes stiff.
That's a broken jaw.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Oh yeah.
See it.
Show that again.
It's a Hamas is high set.
Oh,
so he lands at once behind the air.
But watch this one.
Show that again from the very beginning.
[inaudible] keep the volume up.
Go to the very beginning.
That must be so hard if you're for us.
Yeah.
Man.
Lands here behind you right there.
I said how I'm also thinking about spinning and that's when he did it.
Two in a row.
I think he's stunned them with the first one and then I think the second one
just look at his face,
dude.
His jaws jaws sorted.
Blocked.
Yeah.
Just got smashed.
Nothing worse.
As a perfect example though of like how good elbows are,
like if someone gets really good at spinning LLC or c gas,
Don Bolano is fine.
No,
you're also not going to break your elbow.
Right?
He can smash people in the face sometimes guys have chunks of shit though.
Floating around their elbow.
Yeah,
like splinters.
Like Anderson had some stuff for move from his elbow and Shaka Ray did.
Zachary had some stuff.
He had so much stuff removed from his elbow that I like fill a cup.
Like he pulled pictures out on the line like chips.
I've,
I've actually had drained my elbow like a motherfucker I just put to put a
needle in there.
Just keep sucking pops if you watch my share flight.
Right.
Literally,
I'm in the back of the stage,
like draining it cause it kept Franklin for the fight.
Yeah.
Cause I was worried that because he was arrested,
I was like,
if it takes it down,
let's throw some elbows and mom,
like I got this fucking baseball pad here.
I got a drain it.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
Was it painful or was it just swelling?
No,
I was just swelling.
It was just,
it was just stupid.
Felt like it's like at a big titty on my arm.
He had a tit on my arm and we just kept painting it.
Do you find the pictures of Jocko raise,
uh,
debris that was in his elbow because one,
I think I showed it to you before.
When we looked at it,
we were like,
what the fuck?
Like that was in his elbow.
Like it's like a cup of it on the operating table.
Like there it is.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
That's all the years Jitsu,
Huh?
Just grinding on people's face.
I think it's probably not tapping and then it's probably sparring.
You know,
you've got to think he's doing a lot of kickboxing,
sparring.
What's right.
Click on that other one.
Is that a cup size comparison?
Talk somewhere else.
Go back to his again so we could stare at what was inside his fucking elbow.
That's crazy.
Look Chunks.
It looks like,
looks like teeth worn and yeah.
Yeah.
Well some of it is probably cartilage.
Some of it's probably bone.
Um,
a lot of people are saying,
you know,
Anderson Silva has its fight against the Kelvin,
but they're like Anderson,
GSP,
Woo.
I feel like that ship sailed though.
Well,
I'll tell you what,
if Anderson Lights Up Kelvin gas,
it's,
it's not saying highlight,
knockout.
Yeah.
Flying knee,
k o at 85,
like he hit best bang.
Remember what the,
when he hit best pant,
that flying knee and then Bisbing came back and won.
Yeah.
Anderson is,
that was crazy.
Right?
Like Anderson thought it was over,
walked away with his arms up in the air.
So weird fight.
And he,
he,
he hit him when Bisping was calling for his mouthpiece.
Bisping was like,
no,
I need my mouth.
Boom.
Flying knee to visit and get to know.
Yep.
That's on Bisbing.
How about he comes back and wins the next round now.
Tough as shit.
They're British Zombie.
See Anderson.
If Anderson
wins in a big way,
look at that crack and Michael Bisbing crack and Anderson Silva.
That was crazy too.
And he knocked Anderson down.
Hell yeah.
What it was like,
oh,
that's one of the greatest sites on them in a weight history.
Don't sleep on it.
Slept.
Made the Biz being kind of legend there.
Yeah,
it was a big fight,
man.
Huge fight.
That was a big deal.
You know.
I mean,
look at that.
Boom if dude and but also Anderson.
So much taller than Kelvin is issue at 80 85 is size.
Yeah.
But I'll tell you what,
Calvin has stupid hand speed man and beautiful combinations where he fucked up v
tour.
Like dude,
who's fucked up [inaudible] like that.
Standing before told his father old been through wars,
been beat up,
but that looks golden.
Snitch.
Golden snitch was like Beto you're golden.
Snitch changed going to drain the future.
Vito Belfort,
change the future of everybody.
But even before the Golden Snitch,
just the whole getting rid of the testosterone replacement therapy for sheriffs
before.
But think about,
you know when he,
when,
when Kelvin,
again,
I love Kelvin.
I think he's actually a natural one 70 I think he's going to be better at 70
because look when he went to get sky like Weidman who's an upper echelon or the
fiber,
it's just a different level man.
And when I bigger brown,
just as fast and technical,
you're just,
it doesn't work like that and widen.
It has a crushing top game.
Phenomenal grappling game.
Especially as top game.
His,
his ground game from the bottom got exposed a little bit in the Rockhold fight
also shows you how good rock holds top game is.
Cause Rockhold is up fucking monster when he gets on top of that rock holds a
black belt.
Rock holds a black lid on the grid.
Shot super legit.
Right?
But so is Weidman.
Carmen's a black belt in the ground as well.
I just think his,
his bottom game is not like this top game is insane.
He gets on top of you like exactly the way he did.
Uh,
Calvin,
he gets that choke down on you,
that head and arm choke and you're fucked.
But he just doesn't have the ability to get up or to be very good defensively
off of his back the way some other guys do.
No bottoms.
Tough man being really,
really good.
Yes.
Because such a high level,
such a high low to be effective and like be a threat down there.
Yep.
Yeah.
And Rockhold is also used to sparring with Cain and used to spawn with DC all
the time.
He's used to constantly grappling guys way,
way bigger,
way heavier,
way stronger.
So he smoked in 400 strong is Tom came so strong,
it's a monster.
When he got David Branch down and he's on top of them,
I don't clamps those legs together.
You're like,
oh,
he's fucked.
He's not getting up.
Right.
And she's hands off.
John Donne her black belt to hate.
I'm like,
you know,
kinda silly.
And he smashed him to the ground,
just smashed them.
So like him versus GSP would be crazy.
Block a Rockwell.
Just be known.
Yeah.
Luke Rockhold,
GSP Kimber's,
JSP.
Fucking Craig Anderson.
Silva,
GSP.
No,
I'm saying Anderson Silva.
GSP would be interesting.
Lock Rockhold versus how you know to crazy,
crazy,
crazy.
If you're a Rockhold fan,
you think rock.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Tell him call smash and Hulk Smash.
Yeah,
whatever you want.
He's GSP is too small for them,
especially if it's cardio issues.
Rockwell can go to and watch his fights.
You know his strike force day flights with jock gray and Tim Kennedy like he can
go,
that boy can move.
Yeah.
That's a bad idea for GSB.
I know,
but it's still pretty see it.
Hell yeah.
I want to see,
I'm interested in seeing GSP against a real dop level middleweight other than
Michael Bisping.
I'd rather see my 70 I do too.
I want to see him at 72 but I'd also like to see,
I mean,
I would like to see if we're right about him carrying that extra weight.
I'd like to see if we're right.
I mean if I was in his corner,
I wouldn't say that if I was in the,
no one is saying,
hey look,
we're going to go to one 70 and uh,
we're going to spike terminal these punch
for Ross,
Freddie Roach.
Like,
no middleweights really not where we should be at.
Yeah,
I would tell him at a one seven if you go down to one 70 and you find the title
eliminator fight against Colby Covington or someone,
someone who's like an up and coming guy once and not fight Woodley right away.
I don't think Woodley's going to fight right away.
I think we'll,
there's going to be out for awhile.
If I had a gas then you do an interim belt.
I don't,
I mean,
I don't know what the real extent of his shoulder is,
but uh,
it's not good.
Yeah.
And he's starting to do some kind of outside the ring stuff.
He has a show on TMZ as a podcast.
He's a movies.
All that stuff is great,
but I would like to see it.
Not really.
I mean,
not if not,
if you're trying to be the best in the world,
I don't believe,
I don't believe in this day and age of mixed martial arts.
You can do that and still be the best of the best.
Is he able to train it all right now?
Do you know?
I don't know.
He looks in shape,
you know Woodley.
So he takes care of business,
right?
So He's probably something.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
I'm sure if your shoulder's fucked up,
he's probably not doing any real intense grappling or anything where he's got a
really swing his arms around your boy d seats right in a owes Mer.
Right.
That's the big crunch for that fight.
Hosting them.
Scary.
Yeah,
it's scary.
Can Do.
It's nonstop.
He fucks you up.
He gets you in a clenching lands,
bonds,
giant hands,
dude.
Shake his hands.
Like shaking his table.
Yeah.
How long?
How long do you think that fight in the halls on its feet for 30 seconds over
under three seconds.
10 of Columbia DC come out in a single it or it helps this work.
You know what I'm saying?
It's going to give him his fucking mile high privileges.
Yeah,
man.
He's going to get that under horn.
Yeah,
he's going airborne and he sees a monster.
Yeah.
I mean people forget,
but watch what he did to rumble,
you know,
demand students.
DC's a tremendous,
tremendous wrestler.
Did DC same thing to you about Kane Kane starting to train.
Yeah.
Cain wants to get back in it,
you know,
but he is that back surgery and to,
it's a pretty significant injuries.
Knee surgery,
back surgery,
shoulder surgery,
so that a lot of shit wrong.
So He's trying to make sure that everything goes to right way.
Meanwhile Francis and Francis keynote in Vegas at the fucking UFC lab just
getting failed with whatever the fuck they're giving them.
The all right king come back to that.
What do you think they're testing them with?
Like what kind of shit they do to them with the UFC lab year,
if the UFC is smart,
they'd be like,
this is our guy like Indiana said this Dana and said he might be the future
wolf.
I mean what man,
look,
he's got to fight Allister motherfucking Overeem.
And you can never sleep on Alistair Overeem,
the most decorated,
striking fighter in the UFC.
If they start,
if they start standing in front of each other and in Ghana starts moving forward
and he doesn't protect that left leg,
Allister starts slamming meat into that left leg.
No,
you're gone.
Yeah.
Ousters way more technical.
Way More tactical.
But the thing about Alster is Allister's fucking leg kicks are some of the most
underrated aspect of his game.
So as his grappling though,
forget how good is crap.
It's just he can't,
he can't take his shot the way some of these guys here,
they take a picture of Uber Room.
Yeah,
that's right.
The Overeem now like runs backwards and shit when you throw.
Right.
That's working.
But that's the Brock Lesnar days.
Yeah,
that's Uber.
Yeah.
Be Real.
That ain't the guy he's fighting as we'll show a picture of wolverine up there
that it's not,
you know.
Nah Man,
I don't think so.
That's a photo shoot.
Okay.
Go to his last fight.
Who did Allister fight a JDS,
right?
Knocked him out.
No,
he had one more fights instead,
at least jds.
I think he knocked down.
Is that when he Morocco?
Yes.
That's who it was.
He knocked out GDS before he fought for the title.
That's right.
Yeah.
So him versus Mark Hunt weigh ins.
Is that the wins?
Yeah.
See that's real that that's,
that's Maria Flook.
Yeah.
He's still,
he's still jacked.
Still great athlete,
but he's not steamrolling people the way you used to steamroll people.
Well,
he's D flatline.
Mark Hunt though.
Dude.
He did flat line with that knee.
But like remember when he fought Todd Duffy in Japan?
Like that was,
that was full burrim right?
Uber Room was also,
Oh my God.
Lou Brock Lesnar fights the best.
I look at that knee.
That's insane.
That is a perfect placement.
And he's got some of the best needs in the fucking business,
man.
He's so talented,
Now that you thought in the golden snitches,
like now you gotta fight for reals.
Now he's using his technique.
He's been a lot more smarter.
Look at that again.
Watch this.
Oh,
how dare you flatlined Marco.
You son of a bitch.
That is a full flat line too.
I'm a market fan.
Yeah,
me too man.
Uh,
I think he's done though since they pulled them off that card.
You don't even if he flies out to and does the test and allow them to do well
he's gotta do it now.
But they offered it to him before and apparently he said no,
I don't know what the story is though.
I mean I,
I know he has one store and he has a story that he thinks involves the lawsuit
that he put on the UFC after the Brock Lesnar fight.
Cause he says that they knew that Brock Lesnar was on steroids and that they
made him find his lawsuit.
But the only,
the only defense that has,
you know,
Dana said this in his statement,
he was hold up,
we had them headline two cards and we paid him 1.6 $7 million since then for one
flight.
And he goes,
if the lawsuit was an issue,
why the fuck would we do all,
it's also
yanking Omar for card,
this gray zone defendant Dana here for a fighter but also yanking on my foot
card for a paper view in Australia hurts the you fcs business model?
Yes.
So they would,
they're also protecting their ass because it's on record that he says he's
having brain issues and then they put them in a main event and this even bigger
deal.
Then you're really going to sue the fuck out.
And he said it's only one.
He has a couple of drinks.
That's when he starts slurring his words or each bro.
He didn't say it the right way,
you know?
No.
If,
if you look at that interview,
it really wasn't based off that.
It kinda got a context.
But you know Mark Hunt does have to own it.
He did say that,
say it and he said it in an interview,
but he thinks they pulled him off the car because of the lawsuit thing.
Doesn't make any sense.
It doesn't make sense to use.
He's like,
ah,
cause Vodoun verse,
I forget the ice fighting.
It isn't a,
that's not a big paper you for Australia,
it's not a big card.
Right?
Mark Hunt is a fuge fucking drawn Australia.
It was designed to have him fight on that card.
He's fine.
Yeah,
he's fine.
Marcin to Bora.
Who's a striker.
Yes.
So for dooms going to most likely take dot Chi to the ground.
And you know your Boy Walt Harris finally fought again after getting fucking,
but did you see the fight?
Yeah,
I did,
man.
And you guys were like,
yeah,
I don't think he's a bad dude.
He blatantly meant to kick that.
Do delay face.
We're on the same page once we watched it again,
we listened to the part where the referee says,
stop,
stop.
And he's right in front of him and he's still a kid and they throw this giant
lake.
He got caught up in the whole thing and it's a fight and I believe him.
Nah,
come on.
But,
but look,
that means you got caught up.
He decided to kick that guy anyway.
Like you couldn't pull it back in time.
Whether you're caught up or not.
It's a cheap shot when I call it back in time.
No.
You kicked the door in the face while the ref was between you or you wanted to
hit him.
Yeah.
That's a cheap shot and put yup.
It's not 100%.
No,
it's just a cheap shot.
I don't think Walt Harris is a bad dude,
but he did something bad.
He did something bad.
You fucked up,
whatever.
That's not crucify the Gab.
Yeah,
it was super dirty.
And at the end of the fight,
like when that dude got uh,
illegally kicked in the ear,
that was literally nothing.
Yes.
You know,
but you have to think about what happened before that.
[inaudible] yeah.
Like what happened?
He got poked in the eye.
Oh No,
you get hit in the nuts.
He thought he had hit in the nuts.
He moved away and walk,
came after him to a punch.
The referee said stopped and then he threw the head kick and caught him with a
head kick.
Pretty clean,
pretty clean.
I don't,
was it enough to stop the funnel?
It was like a slap to the face more than it was still like it's still a
heavyweight thrown that whatever 17 size shoe he wears at your face.
No boy,
you know he's enormous.
Yeah it was,
but it was a hard shot.
And then you know,
he had some time to recover and then he'd beat the shit out of him again and
then hit him with the illegal shot.
Then they asked him,
the doctor talked to him and what's her name?
Oh God.
Beer.
God.
Yeah.
And God beer said he couldn't go on.
But yeah,
I mean that's fair.
Me and kicked in the face.
Like I said,
I don't think Walt,
here's the bad dude,
but I'm conflating the two fights.
I'm conflating that with the um,
um,
Curtis blades fight.
I didn't see the Curtis Blade fight.
Okay.
That's where I fucked up cause the Curtis blades fight was a cleaner results,
but also in illegal shot,
Curtis is beaten the shit out of this dude.
This was a Olynyk I was,
I was thinking you had won Harrison.
God Beer.
I got confused.
The God bearer,
Walt Harris thing did not look like it was enough to stop the fight.
No,
but it was a cheap show as a cheap shot.
God is like,
yeah,
I'm fucked up.
I can't go.
Then he'd won the fight.
I agree.
The correct decision,
the other fights where I fucked up was blades and Olynyk blades is beating the
shit out of Oli neck.
And then um,
he went to throw a shot.
That would have been an illegal shot,
but it didn't really hit him.
He just told his ear,
he hit his ear with his toe and they have the baby,
but the referee saw that there was contact.
So he said,
look,
I have to stop it because it was an illegal shot and it was contact and he
brought the doctor in and only nick was done.
But he was done from the beating that he took for that.
So blades one.
Oh good.
Yeah,
it was good.
But it was like super confusing for Curtis.
He thought he was getting disqualified.
We have to calm down and he had beat the shit out the dude before that.
And you could really tell that the toe just barely touched inflicted there.
That Curtis blades,
he trains with all my guys back in dem.
Right.
Everyone's,
I mean,
they're saying these are the next big thing.
If he keeps going,
he keeps going and keeps getting better.
You see him better and every fight his striking as a ways to go,
but they're like,
he had bad shit.
None.
Yeah.
And this year it's getting better and better and better.
He got leg kicked quite a bit by that big Russian dude that Russia who does the
same Russian who knocked Travis out that his strangled Travis.
Yeah.
The only neck mother fucker does not go away.
Did he strangled Travis?
Yeah.
Did he not come out on like a sideways where naked choke.
Remember?
Oh,
that's right.
He's just a fucking Netcracker.
He's the guy that won from Ezekiel from while he was mounted,
let the dude mountain and something is equally and um,
I guess that's a shit.
Yeah,
he's done it to multiple people.
He lives so God damn strong.
I'll tell you that man.
Scary when he gets a hold of people.
It's like his walkout music.
It's like rare last.
Do you hate fans?
Russian,
Russian religious music,
blues,
Bro.
Lose Fudge did fade or select your walkout music.
It's not working.
Have you seen that documentary yet?
ICARUS?
We talked about this,
right?
Did you see it?
No,
dude,
you got to watch it.
We can't keep talking.
You'll go crazy.
You know what the problem is?
How I see you.
You have to watch it.
Watch it.
You know what the problem is?
Give me an assignment to to make it fair.
All right.
The problem is is like I listened to the homeboy who came on and talked about it
and then we've talked about so much.
I feel like I'm good.
Yeah,
but when you see it,
like if you gave me a breakdown of the first season of narcos and we talked
about all the time,
I'm not going to,
I got it.
Spoiler.
You're definitely right,
but when you see it,
the visual,
the way it's done,
he did an amazing job putting the movie together.
It's the way it's done.
It's like shows you where the building was,
where they hid the urine.
How they got the urine pass through the wall.
They had a fucking hole in the wall.
How they opened up the jars.
They show the scratches on the jars and it's like,
Dude,
they rob the Olympics.
It's crazy.
The Olympics in Russia and they robbed it.
They had a record number,
13 goals and they were just all on steroids.
Here's my question for that.
So when I see that stuff obviously is not hampered happening just in the
Olympics.
How,
what's going on right now in big professional sports?
Just think how much money's in the NFL,
NBA,
UFC boxing,
like who's in the know?
I would love to just be a golden snitch.
It's,
you'd have to get the kind of,
and this is where the UFC should be credited because you'd have to get the kind
of access to the UFC has and they'd given to Novitsky in the UFC and Usada like
what they do is unprecedented in sports.
What they do isn't like any other sport where they just you,
you're treated as if you're in an Olympic program,
like where they could just show up at your house at any moment,
your entire career,
your entire career.
You have to give your whereabouts.
Everywhere you are all day,
wherever you're going to be exhausting.
Oh my God.
It's expensive too.
Like even a,
what's the name?
Of course he doesn't have to do this.
No,
they don't.
No one's asked him to do this.
I don't know if this is the best choice,
but I don't think it is.
Yeah.
In today's climate and environment,
I'm not advocating cheating.
God,
I don't think you should cheat a little fun though.
No,
come on.
Come on.
What are we doing here?
Let Jon Jones fight.
How?
Shake free.
John,
I don't know about all that.
You want to know the craziest fucking rumor that I heard about Jon Jones Stein.
Please,
sir.
Car and I can't tell you who told me this.
This is the craziest one.
Yeah.
The,
the stuff that he tested positive for and what the does,
this doesn't make any sense.
And people were saying that there's so many months out.
The stuff that he'd take tasted positive when he was 10 when he's tested here
and tested there.
The stuff that he tested positive takes a long time to get out of your system,
right?
Yeah.
That he was tested positive.
You know where else that stuff you find it,
you find it in Korea team when they get creatine sometimes from China.
It is a,
it's tainted with steroids.
They use that creatine to cut cocaine.
So he's doing the coca.
Here's one of the things that they cut some cocaine with is creating cause it
looks like cocaine.
God.
So he might've got one big stuff,
got bad batch if he was party a monohydrate,
cocaine up,
up pop up party.
John want to do a Bob?
But truly good stuff.
Amen.
I can't test positive for anyway.
It's just cold
be out of your system.
The moral bro.
Woo Damn.
Actually feel pretty swollen to full song comes on the radio,
start dancing.
Pitbulls forget about all your worries.
Have for you the biggest [inaudible] let it go.
He would make the same
birthday 10 days out before the UFC fight.
Oh,
what are we doing?
It's like the world wants them to be a fuck up.
A birthday cake.
Of course.
You knew a couple of bumps on your birthday.
My birthday,
the world.
John,
last time you fucked him up three weeks out when he did.
Come on man,
Bro,
you barely trained.
Um Oh my God.
That's the case.
Just stop and think about it for a moment.
If it was that stuff.
That's best case scenario.
Oh yeah.
That's the best case.
It's code and we can track and we can,
oh,
you can't drive.
You deals go y'all homes.
Let me come in and talk to you about where I get my shit in Columbia home.
Do you guys want to go down there?
You're welcome.
No stitches down there.
We'll take you in the propeller plane,
Bro.
You travel across the border.
We don't have to go do that in a bit ski.
Look how bad you want to catch this guy.
Well,
they don't want to,
they're not in the business of drug enforcement,
right.
They don't want to catch that guy at all and no,
the guy's not going to admit he's not going to give you a bag.
Is the plot of Narcos for John?
Just write narcos for it for Don.
John didn't tell me this,
so somebody told me,
somebody told me this as a rumor,
which sounds crazy,
but then red band was the one who called the Dick Pills last time.
Red Band said that if he's taken dick pills,
like if the guy does coke,
he tested positive for coke and red band was like,
if he does dick pills or if he does coke,
he's probably doing dick pills.
And I was like,
what?
And so red band brought a bunch of them in.
He's like,
do you think there's any,
anyone knows what's in these things?
He's like,
they have steroids and all because I've taken Cialis.
He goes,
and I've taken this stuff.
is this stuff's way crazier than yes.
He says it's madness.
Fuck like a wild animal.
He said,
your Dick is hard as a rock.
That's Promo for Dick Pills ever,
it seems like,
but their gas station,
Dick Pills that you're getting from some fucking third world country.
If your world class athletes probably shouldn't be doing that show up in a
bucket that they used to have pain in.
Yes.
100% I mean rhinos,
7,000 yes,
red band too.
I'd be so scared to table Chit.
Brian won't take them anymore.
I'm prying takes everything and he won't take Rhino.
7,000 remember when they used to have that life cereal commercial Mike,
you won't eat it.
He hates everything.
Brian's the opposite of that.
Brian will take whatever you give a Guinea phase,
like let's go fuck it.
Let's see what the Rhino pills do.
My only it he does,
right?
He did,
but my skeptical Hipaa allies there is,
because again,
we're constantly looking for,
and they're smart people around John.
So would this stuff,
yeah,
there's Clomid in there,
but Clomid is a masking agent.
There's a lot of masking.
It wasn't Clomid,
John.
I thought they found Clomid in this show.
Oh,
the old one.
The new one.
The new one was what?
What was it called up?
Some Russians [inaudible] tour in a bowl or something.
Yeah,
Toronto Ball.
Trying to paint that up.
Bitch doe.
If you're John,
you're doing a couple of devils,
Dan Drift and just whatever.
It's your birthday.
That's the case.
But they have found the Clomid.
They did find it in those Dick Pills.
I mean it was in there.
There,
there it is.
But also makes sense though,
wouldn't it?
Like it's a,
it's does estrogen inhibitor 100% but,
but it's also for something else.
If you've been running,
you know,
gear in it,
you take Clomid to recruit things.
So it's in there.
Like I said,
do you have a lot of smart people around you where when the public hears Dick
Pills like us,
not bad.
Right?
Come on.
Right.
It's all good baby.
Right here to go fight again.
Right.
So then now if it's cocaine,
he should be our,
we're,
we're not looking at it for years.
Well,
you got to prove that it's cocaine.
First of all,
this is pure speculation on my powder.
Cocaine was a journalist.
If I was like working for ESPN three source,
you would have already had me pulled out of here.
Oh you and I both be fired.
Fuck at ESPN.
One for our social media too.
Because when I go my sources,
the one guy is in the business whose balls deep usually in this stuff.
No I'm not.
I'm not hearing a whole lot.
It'll give a fuck.
Yeah,
I'm wrong.
90% of the time I was like fuck shit man.
My sources say my sources.
Hm.
I don't have to come up with three people.
But your guy,
the who knows who it is.
Maybe it's the cocaine dealer,
but he should track him.
If I'm John,
I'm hiring some private investigator to track some shit down.
It's too late though.
My God,
I cannot tell you who my guy is.
But he does not have a vested interest in anybody being correct.
He just has what data?
What?
No,
no,
no.
Um,
he has what he has is a possibility and he also was saying,
and even if it's true,
good luck proven that now you're,
you're screwed.
You're fucked.
Oh cause I'll all the commission knows is [inaudible] where the fuck it is.
I would like to find out from people who actually know whether or not this is
possible.
Christine and cocaine.
No,
no,
not that I've heard is true.
I don't think I looked it up though.
I think I heard it from other people.
I just googled it and saw it a bunch of places.
So they used creating Pittsboro size.
See that's what we're doing.
Yeah.
That's what I,
I have my master's in bro Silence.
So see if,
see if it's proven that creating test positive for that stuff
because that would be very,
very unique.
Taranto ball ain't damnation and creating specifically creatine apparently.
Um,
and a lot of the stuff that you get,
if you're buying vitamins,
you're getting in bulk and you're getting a mixed places.
And we had,
uh,
issues that early on batches of Alpha brain that they didn't contain all the
stuff that it was supposed to and that it was a,
it had some stuff that we didn't even put in there,
had traces a set of change labs.
Do you want to buy some right now?
Sure.
We can buy some.
It's a dollar one,
two,
five US dollars per gram coalesced.
The ball Acetate,
raw steroids.
They're animal Malaysia sourced or anabolic creatine cycle.
Tam,
how much is this the very first thing that popped up,
how much is it?
Five bucks.
Oh Shit.
So imagine if like sea wolf is the thing.
There's so much that they sell online.
That's bullshit.
But I bet a lot of this stuff is real.
Steroids.
I agree.
What does this bet ventalin industry limited.
I think if you've got some shit that's like sort of legal,
I bet you could sell it.
You would test positive for it,
but you could probably sell it.
I've done a lot of fucking supplements in my day and I never flagged.
I mean I've taken the GNC stuff that's like extenders,
testosterone,
nothing ever.
Hm.
And if you're a John,
what the fuck did you do?
And see if,
um,
is that,
what does that say?
That just showing you the supplement itself.
Thanks.
So see if you can find creatine contaminated with tyrannical.
So you see that that's what a lot the baseball players get busted by it that
way.
Yeah.
But don't write Chinese creatine Taranto Ball just right.
Creatine contaminated with Taranto ball cause apparently more than one person
has tested positive,
uh,
in various sports from creatine,
specifically baseball shitload.
Yeah.
We'll create team works.
I mean hell yeah.
It gives you a fat face though.
I made you swell up a little.
Hydrate doesn't [inaudible] there's three of them.
The monohydrates like holds water it yes.
He retain a shitload of water.
Fat Face.
Yeah.
Get thick though.
She gets strong real weight on this forum.
But it says there's 42 supplements that are sold at Gnc that can trigger a
positive test for trainable.
And at this point,
this was in 2014 you saw it.
I had only found seven of them.
Were any of them create,
um,
just see,
did,
did anything come up when you googled creatine contaminated with Toronto Ball?
That was,
that was their first thing.
So one of any of those things are creating.
So that totally makes sense,
man.
I mean if you wanted to sell the creativity,
that's the bomb.
Yo.
My creating make you gain mad.
Wait son.
I'll buy it.
Yeah.
For the regular dude just goes to the gym.
Oh look good on Tinder.
I just want,
I just want to look.
Swole son.
Trying to slam them dms trying to swipe lies and tries that Polo Kosta body.
You'll take some of that creatine monohydrate.
Creatine does work though,
like as a legit supplement.
That shit really,
if you want to get like big and strong and creating son,
it's something.
Yeah.
I mean we'll pull your hand.
Me,
but whatever.
It won't do what steroids can do,
but oh no,
you won't be Vituro Uber Anymore,
Jon Jones and definitely get stronger.
It definitely had a real strong,
strong,
yeah,
it's legit.
But also if you eat a lot of red meat,
preteens and red meat so you could,
yeah.
I've got this guy coming on his doctors a fucking,
all he eats is red meat.
Sean.
Sean Baker.
Yeah.
He's done a corner.
Shit.
No,
he's fifties jacked his.
He does fucking sets a dead lifts.
Box Jumps.
Is this purple though?
It looks like a tank.
Yeah.
It doesn't look like he's doing drugs at all.
I'll look a muscle.
There's a bunch of videos and pictures of him and shit.
I'm very curious to see.
Like I,
I've never heard of anybody,
just even just advocating,
eating only meat.
I've always heard the opposite.
I heard if you just read me like your cholesterol,
your blood pressure,
it's hard to break,
break down in your body.
Like it's not the way to go.
I heard little less red meat is the way to go.
Hmm.
That's not totally right because most of what you get when you get high
cholesterol,
there's a giant,
there's a lot of debates,
high cholesterol,
but uh,
but dietary cholesterol is apparently not a big factor.
Really.
Genetics are a big factor.
Sedentary lifestyle is a big factor.
What about just digestion?
All that red meat?
Yeah,
that'd be hard.
I would wonder.
I would wonder,
but I wonder if like,
maybe it's not that hard.
Maybe it's
the illusion.
I think this,
there was a study that was done on red meat.
Um,
there was talking about,
uh,
what percentage of people got red meat or that ate a lot of red meat.
We're likely to get cancer.
And the criticism of that study that I read that was really interesting said,
this study is not differentiating between what kind of meat you're eating.
It's not talking about eating steaks,
it's talking about just renting.
So what are you eating with that red meat?
If you're eating red meat five times a week and you have a higher likelihood of
cancer,
it's entirely possible that you're talking about cheeseburgers.
It's entirely possible.
You're talking about fast food and bullshit and sandwiches and stuff with a lot
of simple refined carbohydrates.
A lot of trans fats.
Who knows what the fuck sugar,
you're not saying,
oh,
did you eat grass fed beef or bison five days a week?
Or did you eat bullshit five days a week?
Did you eat a fucking sausage?
Mcgriddle you know,
who knows what the hell is in that thing,
right?
You know,
like what are you eating with?
It is inbred.
Are you eating it with pasta?
Like what do you,
how often are you eating?
Refined carbohydrates,
like all these other factors could also be contributing to your heart attack and
May.
They might be the difference,
but it's like one of those things get put out there and then it just stuck with
me like,
fuck,
I can't eat too much red meat man.
He carved to digest well that's,
I don't want to look like Hulk Hogan.
I think balance is probably good for everything.
You know?
I think it's probably good to eat a lot of fiber.
Let me just seems to be who you shit a lot.
That seems good.
Like when I did a giant salad,
I take massive dumps and it comes out like a water slide.
Woo.
Yeah.
Let me just plug,
or if I want to hear what homeboy has state,
maybe you can just eat red meat like a damn cave man and be great.
Well,
he's doing it.
He's,
he gets all his vitamins from that too,
which is insane.
Apparently he's taken supplements.
I would like to ask him.
I can't wait to talk to him.
I don't know if it's the right move.
I know,
but here's the thing.
It's like the right move for you is not the right move for him.
It's not the right route for that dude out there.
It's like everybody's got a different there.
Everybody's body's different when it comes to that and some people just react
really well.
All fish,
like you were doing that for awhile on pescetarian.
How'd that go?
Two weeks just to cool.
Well,
yeah.
it,
It's like,
all right.
You know,
you get bored of fucking fish.
I like to mix things up.
I like to challenge myself with diets,
but then sometimes,
sometimes it's like I don't feel great.
I'm not doing anymore.
I don't feel great doing that.
I gave it,
to be honest,
I gave it over four weeks pescetarian I was like,
I don't feel great.
I'm,
I'm sluggish in the morning.
I feel like I don't have a lot of energy from my workouts I'm not doing anymore.
To him I had red meat and I feel better.
That's some carbs meet back in the system.
Yeah.
Doug,
did he never even eat and elk yet?
No.
Next time you like fucking,
I'll give you something.
All right.
The next time you're here man.
I'm going to grill.
I've got a grill in the back.
When you go and grill the grill?
No.
Are you guys doing companion Saturday?
Huh?
Can't make it.
I can't make it.
You can't make it?
Yes.
It makes me happy when you can't do it.
When I can't do,
I hate being a hater.
Can text me.
Are you texting your companion Saturday?
Go Fuck.
I'm in Nashville.
I was like,
maybe I should cancel and Hash.
We already had something that I promised I was going to do.
Yes.
I to pull out of it.
Family stuff.
Yup.
Huh?
Yeah.
Take that.
Indeed.
Yes.
Did.
I can't wait till the day.
We do only fight companions.
That's going to be fun.
I'll do like one event,
one live event a year.
That's going to be my next contract.
You just work at Madison Square Garden for the biggest card of the year.
That's exactly what you should do.
Exactly what you should do.
Can I say this like in a lot of hate,
I'm sure that we get hate from everybody,
but,
and you performed at mass square garden.
I don't get the big like Hoo Rah with mass square garden.
Like it's old.
It's fuck.
It doesn't look that cool.
I know it's the man I know and everyone's sports and like Nick Shit and forever.
Have you ever been at all?
He hasn't fought there in forever.
No.
I get it.
I kind of Rome,
I've never been to Rome.
Well,
when you're in Rome and you just walk in the coliseum,
you're like,
Holy Shit,
this is the history of college.
And obviously the coliseum has way more history.
That's what I want to see.
I want to see a fucking fight in the Colosseum,
but that's what they should do with Connor versus GSP in Italy.
In the coliseum.
You're on the Sutton,
you fuck that bitch out the pure MMA fighters.
Let's right now,
because I fucking hate these two.
These is to sell a thousand tickets and they only sell million dollar ticket.
Yes.
Just Dubai's up in that.
But it's all the ballers there.
Everyone's just covered in gold.
Yes.
Mr t distract kids tours lined up to Ferrari's.
Pull up Ferrari.
Lamborghini.
That's it.
Lamborghini,
the limousines.
Caviar going through the aisles and shit.
Tuxedos.
Champagne.
P diddy changed his name for a fourth time here.
JP,
did he change his name and go?
He did as he did to what?
Love rather latte brother love.
Hey Man.
Has,
he just wants to be called coffee to me.
He said he's not gonna respond to Puffy or diddy or p diddy or any of those
monikers before those previous monikers.
He goes,
I don't feel like I'm the same person.
I'm not that guy anymore.
You know what?
And I hear you all the time,
but I'm stuck with my same fucking late to change my name for that.
Being known as the fight or like changed my fucking name.
Yeah.
Um,
what would you like to be?
I don't know.
She'd come up with something fresh or wraparound.
Cool.
If you're like a wrap or something cool.
Like be smooth.
Yeah.
Be Smooth.
Be laughing
and please welcome your host p laughing.
Laughing.
This is brother love by the way.
Oh
wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Well,
if you can do that,
can you do that?
You did it.
Well that seems,
that seems I'm going to call myself the superfly do you can't call myself super
fly with Jimmy superfly.
Snugger hey,
that's my new name Bro.
Super Fly Dude.
I'm not mad at that.
And you only answer superfly none of my previous monikers.
That's Sean Combs.
Homespun I'll respond to all the ones that puffy won't respond to and fly.
Dude.
He doesn't call me Puffy P diddy.
That's when you know you just don't have the right people around you.
We can just change your name and we'll answer anything else.
That is hilarious.
Oh Hell No.
Do you think he was just high as fuck as he seems so high.
He seemed scared to talk to the camera.
Pull up the video here to talk to the county.
Cause I know when I get so high that I'm scared.
I love brother loves skin tone.
Amazing cow with this little red powerful red.
He's on the beach and he's got like a white hat on like a,
like a,
uh,
like a straw hat and it's him announcing he's changing his dad and he's like,
I just want it.
That's it.
Keep me some volume.
Hashtag take that,
give it to them.
It's played for the beginning.
Cvs.
Yeah.
Lose.
I didn't plan on this and I decided,
well you pray those risks because I knew it could come off as Corny to some
people.
Like,
Yo,
I decided to change my name again.
Huh?
I'm just not who he is.
So serious.
I am.
Before I get it in different,
I get it for so my new name is Love,
Aka rather low.
I will not be answering the coffee,
diddy,
puff daddy or any of my other monitors,
but love of brother law.
Okay.
It's my birthday.
I feel good.
God is the greatest.
I give all glory and I thank my mom and Daddy.
Yeah.
What the fuck does he play it again?
Play it.
That was kind of a great,
play it forever.
He's so high.
He's barely alive.
Hmm.
It's serious news and he's been praying about it.
I know it was risky.
I knew it could from Gucci.
I did my coffee.
Do you think he comes off as Corny?
Nah.
It feels right.
They're here.
Change my name and do
on dog.
I decided to change my name dead serious though.
What's going on,
man?
I got some of serious things in my life.
My girls a side breaking up with me.
Did he walk back in there and once I,
Oh,
you changed your name?
No,
you changed your name again.
Like he's like,
he's on vacation somewhere playing golf.
It's like this edible kicked in.
I'm gonna go back here and change my name.
I bet he thought about it for a long fucking wild.
I was like,
I'm going to let you see his hand holding up the phone.
That's hilarious.
And he zoomed,
man.
Dude.
See his hand holding up his phone and talking to his phone.
I think sometimes you just smash life in every fat,
every lane that you just become a little crazy.
Hashtag take that Hashtag.
Take that here.
That take that,
take that,
take that too.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Hmm.
Seems like an odd choice,
but hey,
why not?
Fuck it.
He did it twice.
I did.
Again,
I was in a gym.
I was editing.
I was in a gym in Hollywood.
He came in one workout mid day and you want everyone to leave.
Oh,
that's adorable.
Yeah.
It could look,
get me out of that.
However he let me stay for whatever reason.
I don't know.
Maybe because I looked like I was gonna put up a fight,
but he came in there with a truck load of bitches.
Did he go?
I was working out with all these girls dancing around him.
I was nervous too around him.
He's about to do some Kevin Spacey Shit to me or something.
I don't know.
I was nervous.
I was a little nervous.
Hell yeah.
He had his,
his tea whole team around.
They did shut down the gym on the bike.
Cute.
They kicked everybody out.
A lot of people had to bounce.
That bitch told people,
Hey,
I know you paid for your dues and you're a member here,
but that doesn't matter cause this guy means more to us than you.
Basically private gym,
private jet.
It was private,
private gym and they're like,
Yo,
we need you to get up to speed duties here.
Private Gym.
I said I got 10 minutes probably going nowhere bitch.
I kind of private gym is that there's probably a gym for a high level athletes
and celebrities.
Yeah.
I don't want to give the gym cause I don't want to shit on them for this gross.
I know.
I just can't believe their kid.
Like why you can't work out with people.
He didn't want people,
I don't know,
maybe super weak on the bench or some shit like 20 fives on that.
He's like,
oh that's it.
That's it.
Try New calf raises just to some bullets.
Shit work to happen.
He's fucking jazzercise.
You only want to see it.
All he does is that uh,
that abductor adductor machine
just in spreading your legs straight.
Nonsense all day.
That shit.
It's phenomenal for your guard.
Alien abductor the Susan's random shit.
Yeah.
Susan Cerasis this random,
forgot her name.
She went summers.
Yes,
dude.
I used to jack after videos when I was a kid.
She was bad as fuck.
Yeah,
but she,
she had the spring that you push with your pussy shit.
The thighmaster.
Yes.
Was it real?
Does it really work?
If tie master,
you should have to show your thighs likely.
See,
wait,
let's see what we're working on.
That too.
She was hot.
Fuck back then.
Yeah,
there it is.
Yeah.
She was pretty hot.
Too Long.
Like she was one of the classic stories in Hollywood of negotiations gone
sideways.
How so?
She was one of the big stars of Three's company and there was some sort of a
negotiation that didn't go well and they removed her from the show.
They want,
I don't know if she wound up quitting or she wrote out the contract,
but at one time company.
Yeah.
At one point in time the,
the thing had gotten so bad that she was only appearing on the show,
on the phone.
She'd be like on the phone calling in wanting,
talking to hell.
Yeah.
It was weird.
And then they were placed here.
They replaced it with a new girl.
Damn.
She tried pulling the ball and move in.
Hollywood was like what?
Yeah.
I don't remember this.
The full details.
I want to say that it was like a manager decided they were going to play
hardball with the network because it was a big hit.
Shots on Roger worked a shit of holiday.
It is the crazy story of how Suzanne Somers was fired for asking for equal pay
on three's company at the peak of her fame in 1980 so I guess John Ritter was
probably raking in all the cheese with some all the teeth.
Can you imagine if they made three's company in today's society?
I did.
The way it gets green lit did an episode of News Radio with John Ritter,
who was he also Super Nice Guy,
like weirdly nice and people always say that about him.
Yeah,
great thing.
Genuine,
nice guy.
Good.
How about your boy on your show?
House of cards,
Kevin Spacey.
They say he's super screwed.
Screw.
Well you hear what they were saying about the,
the actual set and he'd just be grabbing guys,
Dixon the sat and cornering him and God dog.
Just the ultimate take die but just relax.
Well,
here's a little insight into that.
His brother did an interview where his brother was talking about,
um,
I think his dad raping his brother,
like really heavy duty Shit.
And his brother is dressed like rod Stewart in the 1970s with crazy hair and
some yellow leather jacket with rings on and Shit and or something like you're
just crazy.
Fashion loves this shit.
Like why is going on?
You realize,
oh,
these two probably come from an extremely sexually abusive household.
And he was talking about how he thinks that,
and I don't know if this is pre or post allegation because I literally only
watched like two minutes of it.
I read a little bit of it and I'll watch two minutes of it.
And then my little fucking chipmunk brain was like,
next thing,
please see ya.
And uh,
but he was talking about how he thinks it.
Kevin Spacey became an actor because he hated his life and hated like what he
experienced growing up.
So when I saw on else you wanted to be someone else,
but Dan,
was he good at it?
He was amazing actor.
But I don't think his brother was,
I don't,
I don't know if they even addressed his sexual abuse allegation.
They,
um,
like,
cause I didn't really get into it at some heavy shit.
Dude.
Scary shit that went on for so long.
This Harvey Weinstein Shade.
Is it scary to just,
you know,
when I found you want to see something crazy here,
I'll send it to Jamie.
See something crazy.
I found some shit from 1947.
Hold on one second.
I don't know dude.
How ugly are all these sexual predators to they're hideous.
Like Yancey,
my boy coast again,
the Co cues of sexual,
yeah,
like assault me too.
Yeah.
It's um,
it is,
they are hideous,
but it seems like this was what they did in Hollywood and this is the culture,
right?
Like these guys are products of the environment because there's a lot right now.
Jamie if would you be able to put this up?
Email?
Yeah.
Text message.
Sure.
Okay.
Here,
I'm going to send it to you because this is a,
this is crazy.
This is from this woman in 1947 and she was talking about this very thing,
Kevin Spacey thing.
What does it on?
His brother says,
the price of betrayal and deviancy.
How an abusive childhood at the hands of a vile Nazi father turn Kevin Spacey
and to a quote monster who's life was a lie.
Wow.
Damn.
Kevin Spacey was
born.
Kevin Fowler grew up in a Nazi support with a Nazi supporting father.
Uh,
older brother Randy recalls being sexually abused by Father Thomas aged 14.
While mother Kathleen turned a blind eye.
Oof.
Hey listen,
I'd love to see what he did is horrible and he's a monster,
but God,
man,
you feel bad for it.
You feel bad.
Jamie,
look at that text that I sent you.
Um,
there's,
this was a,
again,
this is from 1947 and it was Maureen or o' Hara and she charged Hollywood
producers and directors with calling her a cold potato without sex appeal.
Because she refuses to let them make love to her.
Says the mirror in New York correspondent,
she says in quotes,
I'm so upset with it that I am ready to quit Hollywood.
Maureen says,
uh,
it's got,
it's got so bad.
I hate to come to work in the morning.
I'm a helpless victim of Hollywood's whispering campaign because I don't let let
the producer and the director kissed me every morning or let them pour me.
They,
they have spread word around town that I something not a woman,
am,
am not a woman,
then I'm a cold piece of marble,
a statuary.
Hmm.
Wow.
Jesus Christ.
So that's that.
That just shows you how long it's been going on.
That this is probably what they always did.
These funds are so many more monsters.
Like these guys are the product of the machine.
Well,
yeah,
I mean if you're an intern and you grow up seeing that and then you become some
sort of a studio head and then you see,
you see that everywhere around you and then you're doing it.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Their product didn't invite me.
It's like that's the nature of the business,
which is horrible to say and now it's finally out there.
Yeah.
The Kevin Spacey thing is crazy.
Sucrase ones.
It's all like a lot of 14 year olds that he was grabbing the day,
fuck man.
And then what do you see?
Harvard fucking,
Harvey Weinstein just looks like pure shit.
He tried like going in a disguise that like a sports bar or some shit.
You see the,
no,
he didn't.
He did sir.
Your six,
five,
300 pounds out of shape,
your faces everywhere.
He tried to go into a sports bar with the sky.
There's like a picture of him at a bar and people are like,
are you shitting me and what are you doing?
He really thought he was going to sneak in that that's like the mountain from
game of Thrones sitting at a bar and we're like,
no,
well no.
Everyone knows what the fuck you look like.
Look at this wigs out and let me see it.
Phoenix restaurant hardly see that.
It's hard to see
you.
Sure.
That's him.
Yeah,
that's him.
That picture.
Yeah,
but that picture looks terrible.
That's horrible picture,
but that's hard to tell.
He's been in the Phoenix area where he's completed a one week outpatient rehab
program.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah,
so great.
You can put a hat on in a wig and thing.
We won't notice who
dark shit and right above it,
it's a giant Johnny Depp to sell homes.
Paid debt.
It's still love that guy.
He just goes off.
Yeah,
he's this.
He's that guy made,
he's still just spend,
it could lose homes to repay $5 million loan.
Wow.
Someone home son,
but that's not good.
That means he doesn't have $5 million to pay a loan and he has like 14 houses.
He owns better.
Hey Disney better strike up another pipe.
Can you imagine if you went on,
I just thought hurricane and ride of cocaine for like 17 years and all of a
sudden you woke up and you're like,
Oh
I,
oh,
what?
What is,
how many houses?
Who fucking let me buy all these houses?
18 ounces.
Are you shitting me and wonder why he's suing his business managers?
Like you knew what I was on call by 14 houses when I was on coke.
God dammit.
Poor bastard.
Hey Man.
How many years after retiring from boxing is Floyd Mayweather broke?
Uh,
the,
I mean,
the Conor fight alarms me a five.
Five,
probably five.
Five.
Does he know the company fight at like 46?
No.
None of that ship sail.
You don't think so?
[inaudible] comeback fight at 46.
Nah.
It's just too sad.
His Ego's too big than the market's not there anymore.
I think he tries to talk Conor McGregor into a rematch.
I'm not kidding.
You see color statements about that?
Nobody's saying he said I'd beat him in a rematch.
Adorable.
And I take that dammit.
Yeah,
come on.
Well,
he would have to do something extremely different.
And his training,
no,
no.
There's,
it's just not,
it's,
he's never beating me may whether in a boxing match,
it's just not the,
he was punching him hard.
Right.
It looked like a,
he clipped him with that one hard upper cut,
but it looks like he was pacing himself in savings energy.
It's just that it's just not the way to go.
I get what he's doing,
but it's just not the way to go.
Yeah.
But if you're making $100 million,
it's $100 million.
If he could sucker people into doing it again for $100 million.
Well what do you think the UFC is good.
What do you think the UFC is going to have to do her back?
Cause kind of getting,
you know,
cutterhead his movie premiere,
which I guess destroyed the box offices in Ireland.
I don't know how many perimeters they have out there,
but it's the biggest,
most successful Irish movie of all time.
That's so crazy.
Yeah.
Which is crazy.
Um,
but,
so they asked him,
what do you have to do?
He goes,
oh,
we're not,
I don't have bosses anymore.
We have to be partners,
which has a legit point.
Yeah.
It's a legit point.
He's a different business entity.
But I think part of the points going to be that he can't talk about it.
That's probably the,
I agree.
I think the deal is going to happen.
And then you just,
I'm like,
no,
I'm fine.
Normal contract cause UFC he's like,
Yep,
we get a bit,
we're going to give you some money.
There's also the issue if you're negotiating that you go public with this
negotiation like that.
You want to talk about that?
No,
I mean I guess he does for his brand because it makes them look like a super
ball.
They've got to pay corner now.
They can't just fucking keep on the same deal they had before or not to say
anything.
Well for Connor parts thing is disclosing it.
It's part of his,
his swagger is how much money's what makes him Conor Mcgregor.
He's beating the game,
which is why she likes the game.
Let's go to be parity now.
That's gotta be,
it can't be.
The older deal can be the old deal.
So you think they give them a apart?
I think if I was the UFC I would do what it takes to be in the condom or Greg of
business.
Now I don't know what that means because I don't know shit about business.
That means you're given a percentage of your company.
You got to give up a percentage if you want a percentage.
Okay.
94% like this movie.
Fucking fucking amazing.
It's fucking amazing.
94%.
It's outside of all the movie theaters here.
I don't know about all,
but yeah,
I think a lot of them probably find those fucking 6% piece of Shite.
Jason through the streets of doable in just 6% of Nate Diaz fans.
Yeah.
What is that about?
Who are these 6% fucking haters?
Super Haters,
right?
Pure haters.
Particulars.
So you're not getting the Nate fight then if Tony in a kind of fight,
say that again.
You're probably not getting the Nate fight any time soon if no co,
cause Conner's team says to that Tony's the next fight,
which is management says that,
and Dana says that.
So what do you do if your name,
I think they don't want to do an eight fight.
Who Does?
Oh,
you think Conor does it?
Ah,
I think,
ah,
I think they take,
Nate is a big fucking guy.
He's long.
He's a rough fight.
They had a rough for them.
Tony Ferg.
I think they're both rough fights bolt.
Neither one of those up.
I want to walk in the park.
But after coming off of that real hard fight with Nate,
maybe he thinks Tony's easier to hit.
No,
although,
well he hit made a lot too though.
Yeah,
he did hit Nate a lot,
but,
and it's at 55 but plot plus,
which is going to get more,
what's going to get more hype Ne.
I agree.
But,
and he was here.
He'd argued going to be going crazy.
Tony just star Super Star.
I went to Eddie.
Got To relax.
Yeah,
but you know,
Eddie trains him.
Totally understand.
I honestly want to see each fight equally.
I really do.
I don't have a favorite.
I would love to see Nate and Connor go at it again.
I would love to see Conor go out with Tony.
I literally do not have a favorite.
I love both of those fights.
What happens if you only get,
you get one five that have kind of come,
he goes,
I'm only fighting once.
Tony,
I'm gonna let Joe Rogan be.
The Guy Decides yet.
Tony Nader,
GSP,
Tony,
because we haven't seen him fight Tony before.
We've seen him fight Nate twice.
GSP is such a long shot.
It's a different weight class.
It's one 70 I mean that's all that they mean.
GSP had talked about going to 55 at one point in time.
Do you remember that?
Yeah.
Yeah,
that would,
that would take a long fucking time from,
from the people who I know who are super close with George,
what they want is worldly and then a super fight with Conor.
That's their game plan.
Why are they want Woodley
70 champ?
You're not going to vacate 85 [inaudible] 85 that makes sense.
Dangerous fight.
Hell yeah,
but they're all dangerous.
All dangerous.
Oliver's 85 it's just unrealistic.
That ain't happening.
70 makes more sense.
But look at what Dana said.
Don't call him a liar.
I'll call him right now.
Did you say he's a liar?
He already hates it.
Robert Whittaker here,
he hates me anyways,
so he can't get any worse,
so I don't give a fuck.
But I think he has to say that there's a lot of things where,
you know he's a PR list.
I know he's your friend.
He's also a promoter.
He's the best person in the game.
Right.
So he has to say certain stuff.
So there's just not a wild west.
Maybe George really wants a fight.
Robert Whittaker.
It's entirely possible.
George really likes it at one 85.
Who knows?
I don't know.
Not Happening.
Yeah,
I don't know.
It's not like take it.
It's not like,
yeah,
I'll take it.
[inaudible] sound like Dana's word is bond here where you know,
he hasn't set outlandish shit before to hyper thing.
Let me ask you this.
What do you rather see?
You rather see him versus GSP versus Robert Whitaker or gs free versus Woodley?
Um,
God,
that's a great question.
I got my answer.
Yeah.
Winokur right.
It's so fucking exciting cause we can knock his ass out,
knock anybody out.
And he's aggressive and he's,
he's very technical.
He's striking his fucking wicked.
He's wicked.
What would I rather see ya?
I'd rather see Whitaker.
GSP.
Oh,
okay,
fine.
If I'm on GSPS team,
he's fighting Woodley.
Really?
Whitaker ain't a fun fight for him.
I don't think either fights or fun fight for anybody.
Neither is fun,
but at 85 there's a lot of his,
his stamina.
There's a lot though.
It's just not fun for him.
Well,
it's interesting because Robert Whitaker,
the 185 pound interim champ used to be 170 pound fighter as well.
And he was stopped by Wonderboy.
Yeah,
that's true.
But he was draining himself to make one 70.
And Britta digger again,
we're talking about a 26 year old guy who when he changed weight classes was
probably only 23.
Yeah,
right.
It was about three years ago.
Yeah.
This last loss,
right?
Yup.
Yeah.
He just couldn't make the weight training himself.
And it's hard when you're,
when you're older and he's pretty fucking stout at a,
at 185 pounds.
I mean,
he's not,
it's not small one 85.
He's the fastest 85 in the world.
Were you shocked by um,
Musashi Musashi fight?
Uh,
I think that shows you like how good the bell tour guys are.
Yes and no.
I,
I do,
I think bell tours at a level,
certain guys that are level,
but I think Musashi if here's the interview and he was actually pretty funny in
it,
but he was like,
I had one fucking,
I'm it.
I literally had one night he closed my eye up so I was just going off instincts
and she'll Mancos very tough Mary.
So I've one eye,
he stuff,
that's what you get.
Yeah.
He caught him with one big clanger but he was,
he was the brand and Vera,
he was like before even guys and was like,
I'm going to be champ at middle weight,
lightweight heavyweight and like,
whoa.
I think everyone's going to go fuck rose now.
I just want to be a good person.
God wants you to do first.
I want to be myself.
You can't do that.
Can kick your ass.
And she's like,
our father in heaven help you.
That's some scary shit.
Really got room for one road.
She did it though.
I know,
man.
Very happy.
Me Too.
That left Hook was the fallacy.
One of the most intriguing fights on the car to me,
I gotta be on again,
I've known rose and we have a history in Denver and we had the same coaches and
I love rose.
I bet on or just cause you're such a big underdog.
I S and I predicted,
I thought she was going to get choosing to be a lot of trouble because your
hands just so goddamn technical.
Yeah.
But I think Yolanda didn't respect her,
didn't she kinda overlooked her that that championship,
you know,
those,
those obligations you have as a champion.
I don't think people realize what comes with that.
You know,
a lot of people go over.
Yeah.
I think it was Dana said this or was run like,
he really wants to be a champ too.
You have to do championships shit,
which you gotta sell the fight.
You're the reason why the paper view is selling the,
there's a lot that comes with that.
So,
and it's George retired because he's like,
dude,
I can't relax man.
Yeah.
We don't get to see it very often too.
You know,
like we don't get to see it.
We see little clips here and there,
but we don't know what their schedule's like.
All the phone calls they have to make all the interviews they have common or
talked about it a lot.
I remember that he backed out of the,
when they wanted to do that fight,
he was like,
no,
fuck man,
I'm not doing all that media.
That's right.
Remember they're killing me.
They were going to be pulled them from the car.
Yeah.
He was like,
cool,
I don't give a fuck.
I need to train.
Like you guys are having me do all this media circus stuff.
I've got to focus on the fight man.
And he and they put him through more interviews and then anyone ever of course.
Cause he's never met a camera.
He doesn't like and think that.
He was like,
no,
I'm going crazy.
I remember when him and although they did that world tour.
Yeah,
that was ridiculous,
man.
Over over,
over easy.
How about the F and then the the Floyd Mayweather tour that,
that schedule is nuts.
And I was just a commentator on that bitch.
I was exhausted.
How crazy was that?
That tour where they would stand in front of everybody and talk shit.
I told [inaudible] talking to cities,
it'd be tough for the best comics in the world.
Cup of new material,
six nights in a row,
little loan.
These two fighters,
like the first two cities you saw,
they have their shit together.
It was fun.
Then after that third one is like,
what are we doing?
What do you think would they sell tickets to that of they're giving it away for
free?
I think they giving them away,
but it was packed.
I've never seen some shit like that.
Ev.
Right.
How many different ones that you go to live?
I went to all of them except for London.
How many have,
whether I went to,
uh,
let's see,
I went to the Los Angeles,
um,
New York and Toronto and they did London.
So I went on and the biggest,
what?
Toronto.
I've never seen anything like it,
man.
Never.
Wow.
People hanging off the rafters to get a piece of his nuts.
Scary shifts.
No one like him.
It's weird.
You know,
there's a lot of great fighters right now,
but there's no one that has the same animatic persona,
this fucking quality that makes everybody want to be around them.
No one on the planet.
I,
there's no one even a close second.
There's never been a close second has there?
Nah,
Nah.
Like as far as like popularity,
he's like the biggest by combat sports athlete ever because who else could go
from one sport to the next the way he did?
No,
it was just perfect timing.
Perfect style,
but the,
the talent right now at 55 and 78 it again,
I was looking at 70 I'm like,
oh my God,
the UFC is operating at such a high level.
Talent wise,
it's nuts,
insane visions.
Other divisions.
It's Jesus guys.
We need some life.
Do you think you could ever talk George and to fight and Connor hundred percent
I'm,
I'm telling you it happened at one 70 why?
I'm telling you when I tell you my guys who are super close to George at their
plan is Woodley Conner.
Now a lot has to happen and these guys,
are you me,
brother?
I'm done.
Yeah,
man.
Worldly kind.
Chi.
If George comes back and beats Tyron Woodley,
first of all,
that would cement him as the goat.
He's the goat already.
Let's be honest.
Who you coming back at 36 and winning the middleweight title,
moving up,
finishing him,
finishing pound,
playing him sleep.
But it's still like that's accomplishment goat versus like technique.
Goat technique.
Goad is mighty mouse.
Who's planning last fight?
He always go through that.
Nobody liked that.
Look at George's resume and you're talking about non Usada days.
True.
When it was the wild fucking west,
which that's that creatine lot.
That's a question.
He still worries.
That's a question too about creatine in the bag.
I gotta wrap this up.
Tell everybody where you're going to be this week.
Let's see.
Thursday,
I'm in Charlotte.
Friday,
Saturday.
Xannies in Nashville on the road.
Yes.
Sun Sunday night,
Sunday night.
Columbus,
Charlotte,
Nashville,
Columbus.
Let's do this.
Deepak.
gay.com.
Yeah.
Uh,
I'm at the Ice House Friday night,
Pasadena,
two shows eight and 10,
almost sold out.
Holla.
I love the Ice House.
It's the best.
See you guys.